Mm,
so why aren't there flying cars?
Just jumping right in.
You don't say hi.
You don't say how I you ready?
How's the wife and kids buddy?
Man,
how's life?
How's your book?
It's been on the times bestseller list
for how many weeks?
Oh,
the astrophysics for people in a hurry.
That's one on the.
On the New York Times best.
It was for 67 weeks.
That's pretty intense.
That's,
that's a lot for any book.
Much less for a science book and so that
tells me while all these trump books or
wafting in and out,
this is bobbing like a court,
like a cork on the ocean waves as the
book of the moment that they're either
praises trump or criticized or
criticizes him come in and off of that
list.
So this tells me that there is this
unserved hunger that people have.
There's a curiosity that this is serving
and it's to astrophysics for people in a
hurry.
That's kind of,
that's very purposefully juxtaposed.
It's like neurosurgery in four easy
steps.
You know,
if you saw a book with that title,
you'd have to pick it up.
You wonder what's going on,
not to kiss your ass again,
but I always say this about you and I
think it's important you make learning
stuff about astrophysics fun and that's
what's missing.
You know,
it's not that people don't like to be
educated that they don't like to learn.
They just don't want to be bored.
That's a perceptive point because,
you know,
think of the image we have of.
Let's say you're in a school where most
people don't go to college.
You're in high school and then last day
of school comes.
What do people do?
They tossed their papers in the air as
they run down the steps.
Schools out.
No,
but what's the rock song?
School fall summit.
Was it forever?
Don't ever.
Forever ever.
So that attitude must mean the school
didn't train you to embrace curiosity.
That learning was a chore and now the
Chores are over.
So I think the educational system needs
an adjustment.
Forget whether or not you go to college
because you're going to spend more years
not in school than in school.
Even if you do go to college,
what you want,
I think are lifelong learners,
lifelong curiosity,
where once you are trained and,
and,
and your curiosity is stimulated the
curiosity.
We all had his children.
Your children don't need to be taught to
be curious.
They are curious to the point of
destruction of whatever it is they
touch.
Oh,
what is this egg on the counter?
What is this glass?
What is this plate?
What's under a rock?
What happens when I pull a leg off a
daddy long legs?
You know they are experimenting with the
world.
We don't think of it that way,
but that's what it is.
They're all born scientists and I say
this often,
you spend the first years of a child's
life teaching it to walk and talk.
Then he spent the rest of his life tell
it to shut up and sit down.
It's this,
this is the wrong combination.
So speaking as an educator,
I think a missing component of school.
Is it the teachers?
Is that the curriculum?
I don't know,
but when you get out of school,
you should say to yourself,
damn,
I want to learn more.
It's almost universally accepted to
that.
That's when you're learning ends.
When you get out of college,
it's over.
Then you say you're done and if it
doesn't,
you're ossified in line and that's how
when the job market shifts,
you're not ready for it because you
don't know how to think.
You don't know how to learn and it's the
difference in the in the workplace
between the person who gets an
assignment because I,
I,
Joey,
Janet,
I need you to do this.
That's not in my job description.
I'm not trained for this.
That's one kind of person in a
workplace.
Another kind of person is a,
here's a new task I need you to do.
Wow,
I've never seen that before.
Great.
Let me figure it out.
These are two completely different
species of human being and what the
world needs more of is like the second
case where you take a new task and you
say,
wow,
I get to learn.
I'm going to learn on my own.
I'll ask people who know more,
you just,
you just embrace the act of learning to
satisfy your curiosity and I think this
book is capturing that in the public.
Oh,
it must be doing something.
Yeah.
Sixty.
How many weeks?
Sixty seven weeks.
Yeah.
That's a lot of weeks.
Every morning I wake up,
I'm calm,
but I'm really not calm.
I'm saying,
Holy Shit.
Sorry.
You're alive.
I can't.
Can I say,
Oh shit.
I can say it.
Tyson swears ladies and gentlemen.
And then people think you're a robot.
Now they know.
Oh,
this is great sign.
I think,
and I think your podcast is a great sign
as well,
the success of your podcast and success
of a lot of science podcasts.
Uh,
uh,
that's an excellent that you noticed
that there's a rise of science curious
podcast out there.
Stuff to blow your mind is one that I
really enjoy.
I really love radio lab.
They've always got elaborately
interesting science of annual perennial
favorite.
Fantastic.
So many.
Probably the best,
right?
Yeah.
And,
and yours as well and I love chuck.
Nice.
Shout out to chuck.
Chuck.
He's great.
But what you're doing is you're making
learning interesting and that's why it's
so fun.
It's,
it's,
there's excitement to it,
and you bring a comedian like chuck on
with you.
Things get silly,
but they're also curious and you're
getting these experts and everyone's
talking about these various subjects.
And as you know,
not only yourself as an exemplar of
this,
a standup comedians are some of the
smartest people in the world.
They have that.
They have an awareness of that far.
Listen,
come to the comedy store with me to the
upstage your mind.
Alright,
let me buffer that a serious.
Okay.
No.
So,
so stand up.
Comedians are perceptive people.
Yes.
And for sure.
And they're aware and they notice things
that you don't notice.
They see the same things you do and get
to shape it in a way you never thought
possible.
And then you end up laughing at other
things at yourself.
Was it your idea
to do your show with standups?
So.
So to what we have there,
there,
there were several of us who created
this concept and we,
there's a Helen Matzos is one of the
partners and there's another one who's
now left,
but um,
uh,
what's his name in a minute,
but there are three of us who David
Gamble is his name.
The three of us got together and applied
for a national science foundation grant.
What we said was there are programs out
there that serve people who already know
they like science,
but who serves the people who don't know
they like science or better yet the
people who know they don't like science.
There's nothing for them because they've
already rejected it.
They're not going to tune in to science
Friday because they don't like science
on NPR.
Right?
So what we thought was supposed we bring
in a celebrity,
we've all the pop culture draw.
This is the pop culture scaffold.
We bring in the scaffold and clad the
scaffold with science because whatever
the celebrity does,
it doesn't matter.
There's going to be science in that
person's life.
We had the guy who portrayed Gollum in
Lord of the Rings,
a lot of Sockeye that suit that he had
to wear.
Exactly.
So what we did was we,
um,
uh,
so with the interview and we,
we talked about the technology necessary
to portray Gollum as a light.
He portrayed that live that was not some
law later animation.
He is live and he's got his whole body
wired up for this and he is that voice
and he is portraying it.
So,
so whatever it is that you have done
that you do,
there is some because it's evidence that
science is everywhere.
You're not going to,
you can't say,
Oh,
I'm done with science,
let me sell my textbook and move onto
other things because practically
anything else you do has been touched by
science.
And so startalk is a celebration of
that.
And then it jumps species.
And so now we're on TV now.
All right.
It is a TV show on national geographic
channel.
Start Talk.
And then since you started this,
by the way,
I,
it,
I didn't come here and talk about you.
You started this.
Um,
we're,
it's our fourth year in a row where
we're nominated for an emmy for
outstanding informational programming.
Are you going to keep doing cosmos too
though?
Because they'll cosmos so,
so.
So I have one week remaining out of like
70 shoot days to finish shooting cosmos.
Possible worlds premiering spring,
2019 is the third installment of Cosmos.
If you trace the first one to Carl Sagan
back in 1980,
can I use your segment on wolves on how
wolves became dogs?
Oh,
showed it to my kids.
And that's right.
You see the little wheel spin and like,
whoa.
Yeah,
those,
that's how a dog became a dog or did you
didn't see as I'm sitting at the,
at the campfire and this snowy
environment and they got wolves walking
around me.
They're on these fishing wires because
they are not dogs.
Okay.
They,
they do whatever the fuck they want to
correct.
And when they look at you,
it's,
it's like,
should I rip his neck out now or later
when I'm more hungry?
Did Not.
There's no eye contact with them because
they you don't,
that they don't see you as anything
other than something that could possibly
eat and so you can't interact with them
the way you would with ordinary dogs.
So they're on these fishing,
you know,
high tension fishing wire that you can't
see against the snow.
And they were like hooting and hollering
around me as I described in the name of
that show is.
And the wolf shall become the shepherd.
Yeah.
My friend did a commercial with a wolf
and A.
There's this commercial where he's
running up this mountain and the wolf is
there and at the end of the commercial
they had to get the wolf to snarl.
So what the trainer does is he shows the
wolf some meat and then he pulls the
meat away from the wolf and the wolf
snarls and they're like.
And then the commercials over,
he's like,
no,
is no working after that.
There's no.
You can not going to be near the wolf.
That switch is turned on.
Done.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's crazy.
He's like,
once that thing snarled,
everybody just backed off and the
trainer let everybody know,
like once I get to this point,
we're done.
Like there's no more and that things
like,
okay everybody,
we're done.
Fuck Outta here.
All three of these cosmos is the
original one with Carl Sagan,
the one that,
the privilege of hosting in 2014 and
2019.
Our Co written by Andrew [inaudible] and
she's the widow of Carl Sagan.
Oh Wow.
And,
but she kind of in his shadow back then,
but she's hugely creative and highly
enlightened and so most of the sort of
the,
the soul energy,
if you will.
The what makes cosmos distinct from
other,
from other documentaries where you're
sort of sitting there learning,
you put your thinking cap on your
learning cap on in cosmos.
It's your feeling cap.
You're not only learning,
you're also feeling the science and its
relationship to you to civilization,
to the world,
to the universe.
And her infusion of this.
She's a highly scientifically literate
writer,
producer.
And so I just give a shout out to her.
Just working with her has been a
delight.
Is Cosmos on Apple TV or cosmos?
Cosmos was a after it first after it
premiered on Fox and then went
internationally.
Annette Geo it then went to Netflix.
So.
But I think this run of Netflix is going
to drop until the next one comes in.
I think they want to clear the clear,
the landing zone for the next cosmos,
but it went to Netflix,
but is it available for anyone to get
right now?
Oh,
right now I should be.
I haven't checked.
That's a great question.
I have it all on my dvr and I'm scared
to delete it.
Oh yeah.
I have like six percent less space.
That's what everyone's Dvr.
Looks like.
I got all your cosmos is in there.
Yeah.
So thanks.
Thanks for having.
Having them all in there.
Was that Morgan Freeman show?
But uh,
the through the,
through the warm warm hall.
Yeah,
I got that on there too.
that was great.
That's Joe Rogan thing.
Yeah.
If you didn't have that,
I'd be disappointed.
If I say you're an imposter,
you're a fake.
It's,
it's an opportunity to be entertained
and learn,
which I think is what everybody misses
and I think that's what's missing in
most public education.
People are bored and you take these kids
with so much energy and then you make
them sit still and watch something
that's not even remotely stimulating by
a person who doesn't really care to be
there.
Right,
and they know,
they know this,
they know this intuitively,
if not explicitly that the enthusiasm is
absent.
Yeah,
they could feel it and just it's the
worst way to learn.
It's the worst way and it's so hard to
escape.
Once you get out of that system,
it takes forever for a lot of these
people to just get their excitement
about education back.
You know what I say?
When I address teachers,
we all,
by the way,
I'll do this right now in this room that
we have only three of us,
but let's.
Let's take a show of hands in your life
with all the teachers you've ever had in
every class you've ever taken.
How many had like a singular influence
on who and what you became?
Give me a number.
It's going to be,
I'm betting it's five or fewer.
Probably more like three.
Yeah,
for teachers.
What's your number?
Well,
there's the one that I talked about on
your show the last time I saw you.
Thanks for coming on to start talking
about pleasure.
Um,
who was a science teacher that I had
when I believe I was in seventh grade.
Right.
Told me that if you really want to hurt
your brain,
look up and recognize the fact that that
goes on forever.
That this is infinite.
And then just think about what that
means.
Infinite.
That there really is no end to it.
So how many teachers such as that were
so influential on you that one guy
saying that one.
So if you missed one class,
he might be the one.
And what do you got to?
For me it's like two and a half and I've
had scores of teachers,
100 teachers at least.
So what I tell teachers is be that
teacher to your students.
We've all had those teachers be that
teacher.
And in every case it wasn't because the
topic was something you knew in advance,
you would like.
It's because their energy for sharing
their passion and love for the subject
was palpable and it just spilled out of
him and went into course through your
veins and your arteries and you walk out
of there thinking,
wow,
that was the most interesting thing I've
ever done in my life.
You don't even care what you get on a
test after that because you got touched
and you became an enlightened
participant and that exercise in that
exploration.
Yeah.
It's so hard for them to even get kids
attention though unfortunately matches
going on.
Unfortunately that could be in some
places,
half the energy of the teachers is
maintaining order.
I think the success of your book,
the success of your show,
your podcast and many of these other
really intelligent podcasts are showing
that there's an appetite for this stuff
out there.
Yeah.
And I'm delighted to be a servant of
that curiosity and um,
this,
I brought this just because it's not
even out yet.
This is your earring,
like now live.
This is it.
You realize you were.
Okay.
So this is like a five second delay,
or is that the belief on my ex?
What is the successor to war?
Oh,
this,
this is like another book.
I just,
this is coming out in three weeks.
Was this about space for accessory to
war?
The unspoken alliance between
astrophysics and the military?
Uh,
yeah.
So,
so this other book was astrophysics for
people in a hurry.
If you're in a hurry,
do not buy this.
People that are.
This is not.
This is not what.
This is not an impulse item at the
checkout line that says you got this is.
This is all about,
by the way,
we know what role the physicist plays in
war.
The physicist makes the bomb invents the
bomb,
the chemist perfects napalm,
the biologists weaponizes anthrax and
the astrophysicist,
well we sit at the end of a telescope
and wait for photons to cross the
universe and enter our detector and we
go into conferences and argue about
them.
So there is no obvious connection
between what we do and military strength
had Gemini,
a dominance empire building.
It's just not obvious.
That's why the subtitle,
the unspoken alliance,
it's not a secret,
it's just not there.
It's there,
but it's not.
Nobody's talking about it.
Do you realize.
I just give an example.
Okay.
If you needed more reasons to think that
Columbus was a dick.
Okay.
Let me add one to it.
When we were kids and today.
Yeah,
I know,
but actually I do have something smiled
redeeming to offer about Columbus if you
have the time.
I just want to start off with that.
Do you want me start out with that?
With how you want to do it,
but I'll do the dick part as a dick.
Okay.
So on his third voyage,
he's in,
by the time he have his third voyage,
he had already planted enough Spanish
flags that Spain had already begun to
set up governments and infrastructures
in these places that he had a compound.
Yeah.
Basically conquered and so,
so in one of the places I was in the
book accurately,
but I think it's Hispaniola one of the
island today,
he has to get back.
Is this third voyage?
15.
Oh,
3:15.
Oh four.
He's got to get back to Spain.
He doesn't have enough,
not
enough food for his crew,
so he asks the natives,
would you please give us some of your
stock that you have collected from your
farming?
Now,
this particular group of natives only
makes exactly the amount of food they
need to tie to the next crop.
They don't have surplus,
so they said,
no,
we don't have surplus.
Sorry.
Columbus knew that one week,
hence coincidentally there was gonna be
a total lunar eclipse with a moon in its
orbit around Earth,
enters earth's shadow.
The full moon enters earth shadow and
disappears and that the geometry of that
event,
it's just a simple lunar eclipse,
but the geometry of sets,
that sunlight passes around earth
through earth's atmosphere and takes on
sunset colors that Leech into Earth's
shadow giving the moon.
If you can see it at all,
a deep red amber hue,
almost the color of blood Columbus set,
and he knew about this because he had
read the tables,
the eclipse tables.
All right.
We had known enough about the solar
system at the time to w we we got that.
Okay.
Actually,
back then,
it was just the known world with Earth
in the middle of the known universe,
but that didn't matter.
The rhythms of the universe were known.
He says to the natives,
if you do not give us food,
my God,
which is more powerful than your God
will make the moon disappear and it will
turn blood red.
That will happen in one week.
You have one week to comply.
Some of them were skeptical of what you
can't.
What others said.
We got it to what this guy said.
Look at the ships.
They came in,
their guns,
their power,
their,
their culture.
Look what they've got.
Sure enough,
right on cue,
the moon begins to disappear.
According to that,
that is a famous woodcut.
You know you got this.
Oh,
those viewing the video of this as a
famous woodcut and notice the natives
bowing to him and he stands proudly
because he knows the science.
He knows the astronomy.
He knew this and so he invokes this to
dominate people who are not yet
scientifically literate and within
seconds of this beginning,
they bring them all the resources he
wants and he gets out.
We don't know what happened,
you know,
back at the island whether the people
survive the winter,
but he got back to the island that that
is one microcosm of a set of ways that
the universe has been invoked in this.
I'll give you another example.
Los Alamos national labs,
they today as basically since their
inception,
are charged with tracking the nuclear
arsenal of the United States are nuclear
power.
The nukes that would go into nuclear
weapons.
They think about this.
Do you realize they hire astrophysicist?
I had colleagues work in there.
You know why?
Because there is a room.
There are two rooms.
I mean I'm,
I'm,
I'm simplifying this,
but basically there are two rooms
adjacent to one another and a computer
between the two of them,
the most powerful computers in the world
and there is code running on those
computers that calculate the energy
yield of hydrogen fusion.
That's exactly what an astrophysicist
cares about when stars blow up.
Okay,
the sun is undergoing nuclear fusion
right now and that's how it's making
energy and when the.
When high mass stars dies,
they explode.
Supernova.
This is a natural thing going on there
in the universe on the other side,
that's a classified room.
They're calculating yield of hydrogen
bombs and they have lunch together and
they compare notes.
The government doesn't always have the
best people,
but if you hire some of the best people
to do whatever it is they want and their
calculations happen to relate to a
military project there you have a two
way street in progress.
Why do you think the Hubble telescope
that the,
the,
the mirror issues not withstanding which
were ultimately fixed when it was first
launched,
why was that so successful?
There were versions of the Hubble
telescope previously launched by the
military looking down that,
that the model for that telescope had
already been conceived and built and was
operating.
Then we say,
oh,
we want one of those.
Okay,
but that's not public that this is going
on.
We designed with the telescope,
gets designed as the benefit of previous
versions of it having been used
successfully,
but looking down and we look up,
this is the perennial two way street of
astronomy in the old days and in modern
times,
astrophysics and the invention of the
telescope.
You haven't said anything yet or are you
just.
You're a good listener.
I'll should I keep.
Just keep talking.
What am I preventing you from
interrupting?
Don't worry about me.
Okay,
fine.
Galileo perfects the telescope.
He learned that it had just been
invented in the Netherlands.
The Dutch were were up opticians.
Alright,
so they invented the telescope and the
microscope within a couple of years of
one another.
This transformed science.
When did they invent the eyeglass?
The reading class?
The reading class.
I was earlier than that,
but I don't.
I don't know when the real advance was
putting two lenses in line with one
another.
Sounds trivial in modern times,
but that was a huge leap.
Conceptual leap and what you would
accomplish and in so doing,
depending on how you curve them and how
you grind them,
grind the,
the shape of those lenses,
you would get a microscope or telescope
and and we're off to the races.
That's basically the birth of modern
science as we now think of it and,
and,
and conducted.
Because you say to yourself,
my sense is I don't trust them to be the
full record of what's going on in front
of me.
You pull out a microscope,
oh my gosh.
He got the microscope guy.
He thought he got a drop of pond water,
puts it under his microscope just to
think to do this.
It's just water.
Why do you think that's something
interesting to do?
He said,
I wonder.
He was curious.
He puts it under and sees little what he
described as an macules.
Happily a swimming anime macules.
These are like the Amoebas and
paramecium and Oh,
it is.
And so he writes a heat reports on this
too,
to the scientific authorities and they
don't believe in a,
say a bodily one hook.
We think you might have had too much gin
before you wrote this.
Why would anyone believe this?
That there's entire creatures,
an entire universe of creatures thriving
in a drop of pond water,
and so the way science works is one
report does not make it true.
You need verification.
They send people to the Netherlands to
verify as results and there it was,
the birth of microscopy and then they
looked at everything sells,
you know,
they need vocabulary to describe what
you're now seeing.
Well,
that was the.
The journey down small than the journey
went up big and Galileo perfects the
telescope.
He looks up and says,
Whoa,
I see craters,
mountains,
valleys on the moon,
and the sun has spots.
Venus goes through phases.
This became the Corpus of evidence for
earth going around the sun in Supportive
Copernicus's idea that earth went around
the sun.
My point is,
what was the second thing he did with
his telescope?
He telephone nothing.
He contacted the Doge of Venice,
invited him to the cocktail hour and
said,
look at what this instrument can do for
you.
As we look out into the lagoon,
you can identify a ship's intentions,
friend or foe by its flag 10 times
farther away than you can with the
unaided eye.
Venice bought a boat load of these
telescopes in the service of their
military defense and this was a source
of money to Galileo and now he could go
look at the universe.
This has been a two way street ever
since people have looked up,
so this is.
This is an accounting of that.
This is it's and and it's it,
it goes on and on.
The first x ray machines for airports.
You're old enough to remember.
Why would they put in because of
hijackings to Cuba basically that they
were armed hijackings of airplanes of
American carriers to Cuba and Congress
said,
we gotta do something about that.
Oh,
by the way,
there's a company in Boston called
American Science and engineering that
was building an x ray detector,
small enough to put on a satellite to
observe the universe and x rays at
because no one had zero.
We've used visible light but not extra.
That's a branch or the electromagnetic
spectrum.
We think if there are black holes out
there,
their region surrounding them will give
us x rays.
It's a new window on the universe,
and then they said,
oh my gosh,
there's a call for x ray machines at
airports.
We've got the technology that we've
perfected to put in a fricking
satellite.
So the technology for those ones,
you walked through the airport initially
came initially.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
There was a two way street.
There was,
oh my gosh,
we need this for security.
Oh by God we would.
We were using.
Let's let.
Let's apply that technology to these
detectors.
Well,
that's been a lot of the stuff with the
space program.
Right,
and a lot of the stuff that they devised
for use on the space station and some
many other technologies have trickled
their way down into.
That always happens and even some simple
things because people say,
why spend money up there and we should
be spending it down here.
But there's interesting fact here that
is almost never discussed.
The people who who think about the
universe and study of the universe are
hugely creative and the creative
energies cannot be pre-prescribed.
You can go to,
uh,
create might,
but I don't know that you'll get their
maximum creativity.
Say,
I need you to invent a cure for cancer
right now.
Use that brilliance out.
Try.
But the greatest discoveries,
the greatest cures,
the greatest of these comes from a cross
pollination of interest that people have
that where they were engaged because
they were interest interested just for
the sake of being interested.
So watch now.
Here's an example.
The space shuttle.
It's a glider when it lands.
Okay,
it's got no engines.
It's got flaps.
There's a little bit of brakes and the
tires,
but that's about it when it comes in.
Okay.
How do you make sure the thing that
stays on track because they kept
drifting and cross winds and this sort
of thing.
And so they said,
why don't we groove the road so that the
rubber on the road,
the the runway so that the rubber can
align with the grooves and stay in a
straight line because rubber doesn't
slide well when you have doesn't slide
sideways very easily on crews.
When they realized how effective that
was,
it's now put on off ramps to freeways.
If there's a freeway off ramp that's a
little tight,
not quite banked well enough,
it's going to be grooved.
Check it out next time.
And you could say,
well,
okay,
that's pretty simple.
Low tech solution.
Why didn't we?
Why couldn't we just discovered that on
our own without the $20,000,000,000
a year space agency called NASA,
but you didn't,
you didn't.
Power tools,
cordless high torque power tools were
invented to service satellites in orbit
by NASA because you can't just plug it
into 120 volt socket when you're
floating in space.
So the engineer said,
how are we going to solve this problem?
Let's make a high torque power tool.
So now NASA invents the heightened.
Now
that is the only way you're buying a
power tool today is the,
is the cordless variety,
all construction sites that are looking
for a power outlet for these things.
So why didn't we invent this without the
$20,000,000,000
space?
Right?
You didn't,
you weren't,
you didn't think about it.
You said,
oh,
I can plug it in.
This is great.
You're not even thinking what you need.
So yes,
there are all of these applications,
but,
but I don't think that's a good reason
to do it,
but I don't think it's the best of the
best reasons are my gosh,
don't you want to keep dreaming?
Don't you want to keep looking into the
future?
That would be ideal,
but that's not attractive to people that
are spending tax dollars when it comes
to tax dollars.
People get super pragmatic and they go,
why do we need to go to Mars now?
What we need to do is take care of this
and pay for that and with a deficit and
the budget and you know,
so you know,
and that's his budget today is four
tenths of one percent of the federal
budget.
So if you take a dollar or ten cents,
I will quantify that for it to stay.
Take a dollar bill and imagine that your
tax dollar and you can like cut it to
whatever percentage you want.
So let's cut four tenths of one percent
off of the edge.
That doesn't get you into the ink.
You're still in the white border around
it already.
Even notice that you can trim that off
the dollar and pay for it and pay for
it.
So my point is most of the people who
say don't spend it here,
spend it there.
They think NASA has more budget than it
actually does.
They just,
they.
If you asked them,
how much do you think getting,
oh,
10 percent,
five percent.
You know,
several percent.
No,
it's one half of one percent.
So if you're going to tell me that if
you can take that four tenths of one
percent and spend it in these other
problems and solve them,
I would say,
yeah,
go right ahead.
But is this,
is this where you really want to pull
the money from when it's the only thing
that God has us thinking about tomorrow
is just thinking about a future.
Well,
forgot like you,
that's super important.
But for a guy who lives in Cleveland,
who doesn't give a shit about science?
Oh No.
Excuse me.
That's like the person who says,
okay,
I don't need the space program.
Uh,
why do I need this space for Andre?
I have my cell phone and I have the
weather channel and I know anything I
need,
you know,
this is,
you're using gps satellites to
understand where you are on this earth.
You to notice they were grandma's house
is when you pull it.
It.
Who created what?
Who created spread spectrum technology
that led the GPS and Wifi.
Who is that heady Lamarr?
Oh,
I didn't know that.
Yes,
the actress.
Nineteen 41.
Yes,
she did.
About the underrecognized.
We reminded me of super hot though.
That was the problem.
Nobody cared.
Like,
Hey,
you're smart too.
Yeah.
But yeah,
it would take decades to really realize
that.
Of course,
GPS is launched by the military and it's
now hundreds of billions of dollars
worth of
the American economy thriving on this
space application,
but it was a military intent and it was
to navigate the surface of the earth to
navigate,
and the first Gulf War was the first big
use of space assets in the conduct of
military operations.
I believe in even when hetty Lamar
created it with another scientist.
The idea behind it was for encoded
encoded transcriptions are encoded
information during the war.
Well,
so that's a big challenge.
How do you encode information?
That's by the way,
the future of this might might come
from.
It's still not clear.
The jury is still out in their sort of
opposing views on this,
but you've heard about quantum entangled
particles where I can create a pair of
particles that know about one another
and now they separated in space and in
time and if you observed that other
particle,
it instantly changes the state of the
particle back.
The other particle that's back where I
am,
and by the way that they communicate
instantaneously faster than the speed of
light.
When you say if you observed,
do you mean that if you observe it with
anything,
it doesn't matter,
but you have to do something you have to
do?
Yes,
so something has to interact with.
It's not woo woo,
but people.
But you say that people go,
yeah,
I saw that in the secret.
Yeah,
so the problem is the word observe.
People thinks there's a psychological
thing,
but in physics is got nothing to.
With measurement,
it's a measurement thing and so in other
words,
if there's a.
If there is an electron city in the
middle of this table and all the lights
are out,
I can say I think there's an electron
here.
Let me find out,
and the moment I turn on the lights,
the light interacts.
Photon interacts with electron and kicks
it somewhere else.
So the more I try to measure its
position,
the less I know it's position.
So because you need to,
the measurement requires an interaction
with it and on.
In the quantum scale,
interactions changed the state of the
experiment that you're conducting.
We know this,
we've quantified it.
We don't like it,
but we deal with it.
And in the act of dealing with it,
you can exploit that fact for other
purposes we exploit quantum craziness to
birth the into the the information
technology revolution.
There is no creation,
storage or retrieval of information
without an exploitation of the quantum.
So,
and by the way,
the quantum was discovered in the
quantum physics as a branch of physics
was discovered in the 19 twenties.
If you weren't around back then and your
tax buddies don't like paying taxes,
you,
what would you have said?
Why are you spending government money
on,
on the Adam and on molecules.
And you can't even see them.
What good is it all?
I kinda would work.
I just cared about my would adams,
right?
Here I am.
You have to shove that where your,
where your tax dollar is.
And so it would look like you're wasting
your own time and everybody else's
money.
It would take decades,
five decades,
four or five decades before we had
realized what role that would play in
computing this creation,
storage and retrieval of information.
And by some measures,
it's a third of the world's GDP is
traceable to what quantum physics does
for us on a computing scale.
So anyone.
Yes,
yes.
Well,
I mean,
there are ways to do it.
There are certain industries that would
still be there without computing,
but they're made more efficient with it.
Okay.
So ups tracks all of their trucks with
gps and with a computing devices that
invokes the quantum.
But ups predates the use of this,
these tools.
But you can look at profits relative to
their efficiencies that are enabled by
these technologies as well as entire
fields that didn't exist before
computing.
You add all that up.
It's a stunning fact.
And my only point is that you,
if you want today to say,
why study this when we have these other
problems while I do,
all I do is take you back to the cave.
And let's say,
all right,
we're in a cave and there's a mountain
over there in the valley.
And I tell you,
I told her that the Cape,
uh,
I tell the tribe leaders,
I want to explore that mountain in that
valley.
No,
we can't afford to send you out there.
Now we have to solve the problems first
before anyone leaves the cave.
We laugh at that.
That's an absurd claim to make in
caveman days.
I don't know if anyone did it,
but that's a crazy thought because their
solutions to your problems that might
exist and time has demonstrated,
likely exist by leaving the cave that
you can then discover.
So for me,
x voices,
not just space,
all the frontiers of the unknown
biology,
chemistry,
Ai,
you know those frontiers,
and then you can cross pollinate them
and transformed civilization.
Then the last example I give and then
I'll shut up because I want to hear you
talk to me.
I got.
I don't say I want to hear you interact
with what I'm telling you.
Here's one.
You Ready?
Okay.
My physics professor in college study
the universe,
love the universe,
study gas clouds between stars and
studied.
How would you detect a gas cloud if it's
not radiating light?
Well,
they give off radio waves,
right?
And he figured out what kind of radio
waves they give off and why,
and in this he gained expertise in the
nucleus of the atom and he discovered
that the nucleus can resonate depending
on the mass of the nucleus.
It will,
which means,
depending on what Adam it is on the
periodic table,
it will resonate slightly differently.
When exposed to the same electromagnetic
field,
he discovered a new phenomenon in
physics called nuclear magnetic
resonance.
It would then take a clever medical
technologists to say,
wait a minute,
if you can distinguish one heavy Adam
from another,
let me make a machine out of that,
put your body in it,
and I can then distinguish one kind of
tissue from another.
And thus was born the magnetic resonance
imaging the MRI,
arguably the most potent tool in the
arsenal of modern medicine where I can
diagnose a condition in your body
without cutting you open first.
That is based on a principle of physics
discovered by a physicist who had no
interest in medicine by the way,
that the real title should be nuclear
magnetic resonance imaging.
But that's the other end word.
You're not.
Some people don't like nuclear,
what?
They're less likely to go inside the
machine if there were nuclear was on it,
but my point is that was a cross
pollination of ideas with clever people
on their frontiers.
Looking over the fence at discoveries
that are being made is how we got the
microwave oven.
That was an invented by
thermodynamicists microwaves.
This is a world war two attempt to
communicate using microwaves and they
found out some guys,
chocolate bar melted in the microwave
field and they said what?
What happened there?
And they did some more tests and of
course the water molecule and other
molecules common in food respond to
microwave.
It vibrates them ferociously and so you
put food in our microwave cavity.
The water content of the food vibrates.
Friction cooks the food.
There's still people today who say,
oh nucleus,
because they think it's so fast and they
might still have no fear.
It's just friction.
Okay,
friction it.
Everybody's scared that it fucks up the
food.
Well,
does it?
No,
it's just,
it just heats.
The water,
gets scared.
The Woo people do.
Okay,
so here's the thing.
There's certain foods that don't respond
well to the flipping of the water
molecule and one of them ways like bread
products gets hard.
Yeah,
it gets chewy and leathery and only if
you overdo,
if you overdo,
you gotta do it just right and you're
still good.
If you overdo it,
it can get loud.
That's kind of it.
I'm trying to think.
You wouldn't grill a steak in a
microwave.
You would heat up the meat uniformly and
that's.
That's all it would do.
A cooks bacon pretty fast,
but it's a mess and it splatters all
over.
So you pick the foods that are best for
that situation.
As you would pick the foods best you
wouldn't.
You wouldn't put toast in an oven at 350
degrees to bread to make toast.
We have toasters for that.
Right?
So different things in your kitchen.
Do things best.
You wouldn't make ice cream in your,
you know,
in your,
in your toaster oven,
but people are afraid of microwaves.
The one thing that they're afraid of,
it's not.
It's not that they're afraid of
microwaves,
that they're afraid of things.
They don't understand that your precise
now
this,
they're afraid that something's going to
happen to their food that makes it less
good.
Correct.
And it's just,
it's,
it's not the not knowing that people
fear.
My wife's friend's mom will not eat
something that comes out of a microwave.
Really.
She quotes that as part of what makes
her healthy.
Drinks a lot of water.
She refuses to eat microwave food.
The whole life is around not using
microwave.
She won't eat anything that comes out of
a microwave.
I'm glad that she doesn't.
She'll.
She can live a long,
happy life as such.
She,
her reheat food.
Old School.
Okay.
One of the hardest thing is reheating
was on you.
If you don't have a microwave.
A true.
That's like impossible.
You're gonna Cook it again.
Got To cook it again.
Yeah,
that's a really good point.
So I think microwave ovens were invented
for leftover lasagna and yeah,
just eat a bowl of pasta just in
general.
Yeah,
soup soup is good.
Yeah.
So you don't have to worry about it.
It's not doing anything to it.
It's not.
Not Sucking any nutrients out or adding
any nuclear radiation.
Correct.
It has nothing to.
With radiation in the normal sense,
other than electromagnetic radiation.
It's already light from the bald.
We tend to use radiation in the context
of stuff that would hurt you.
So that would be radiation.
Have high enough energy to hurt you and
microwaves are not in that category.
I never even thought about what
microwaves do until this conversation.
Really?
Yeah.
So it's a certain frequency of
microwaves that beautifully pairs with
the water molecule and it vibrates it
brilliantly,
so it doesn't work for completely dried
things.
Yeah.
That's why if you put something that has
no water in it,
it's not really very useful to have beef
jerky.
It's there's still some moisture in it.
Correct.
It's why it eats the food and not the
plate.
The plate gets hot.
It's not because the microwave oven
heated the plate is because the food's
hot food and the food.
That's why I can usually pick it up at
the hand.
You can put food on a paper plate.
That's right.
It doesn't burst into flames and burst
into flames.
This is crazy.
Joe,
what is the difference between MRI and
Fmr?
Oh,
so an FMLA claim.
Total expertise here,
but I'll tell you the little I know the
MRI,
they put you in there and you're
stationary and then they make this map
of whatever part of the body they're
studying is typically your head.
All right?
Uh,
but you can do it on your joints and
other parts of your body that might
require this level of three dimensional
analysis and it's a three d map of
what's going on in the park that they
surveyed.
And so you look at it slices through
that section.
So you might see in Mris of your brain,
of your skull and they take slices.
You as they slices go through,
you see like the eye socket come in and
then go out again or the the nose
cavity.
And you can look at it in all three
dimensions,
front to back side to side a up to them.
So.
So depending on the sophistication of
the machine,
F MRI is they are looking at your brain
while you were thinking.
So time is now an active coordinate of
what's going on and they're measuring it
as they're talking to you about.
So they say,
Oh,
think of the ice cream Sundae with a
cherry on top,
but think of a naked person who you'd
want to have sex with.
Stands for function,
functional,
right.
And so it's basically a real time
observation of what's going on in your
head.
Evict a person.
There was a woman in India and it's
really highly criticized case,
but she was convicted of a crime,
I believe it was murder because she had
functional knowledge of the crime scene
and the arguments against it where like
if you're going to be accused of a
crime,
clearly you're going to study the
evidence,
you're gonna talk to a lawyer,
you're going to go over some things.
You're going to be,
I don't know if MRI is that precise.
Yeah.
They don't think it is very disturbing
that this was used in court.
It's like,
do you remember when these Italian,
um,
geologists were.
I think they were tried because they
should have known about an earthquake
before it happened.
And then scientists had to say,
hey guys,
this is not how it works.
Like this shit can just happen.
That's so.
No,
I don't.
But that's what I do know.
Let me share a couple of things with you
that I've thought deeply about recently.
There are three kinds of truths in the
world because we're in like a three.
Let me.
I'll give you three.
Okay.
The Rudy Giuliani kind.
So you ready?
True isn't always true.
I know.
So let me try to unpack that.
Okay.
Alright,
you ready?
Okay.
Alternative facts.
I do something called an objective truth
and objective.
Truth is something that is true whether
or not you believe in it.
And the methods and tools of science are
uniquely conceived to seek out and
establish objective truths.
And this I'm in referring to the
invocation of the scientific method.
No one scientific result result research
result is true until it is verified by
other people's research results using a
different experimental method with
different wall current from another
country.
When your competitor says,
I think you're wrong,
let me show how you're wrong.
And they reproduce your experiment and
get the same result when you have
generally the same results emerging that
is a newly discovered objective truth
about the natural world.
And when you have objective truths,
they're not later shown to be false.
That's an objective truth.
Then you have personal truths.
These are truths that you hold dearly.
Jesus is your savior.
Mohammed is the final prophet on earth.
You know Abraham is your.
These are your personal truths.
There's a heaven.
You're going to.
No one is going to take that from you.
Not In a free country where freedom of
expression
and speech and religion is protected.
That's a personal truth.
The problem here is you can't convince
someone else of your personal truth
without some act of persuasion and in
the limit and active violence.
MMM,
okay.
In the limit and the limit.
This,
I get holy wars.
So I have this personal truth and I
require that you share my personal truth
provides.
That's a recipe for disaster and not
unbelief.
Because the people who hold the belief
will tell you that it's the truth.
So I don't want to take that usage of
the word away from them.
Okay,
so you're giving them a good definition.
I'm giving them the word truth,
but modifying it to say personal truth.
That's correct.
I'm not going to.
If they've used it that way for
Millennia,
I'm not going to.
Okay.
They they feel that is true and it's
true in their bones.
I'm simply saying that because it's your
personal truth,
you cannot require that someone else
share it and in this country,
because the United States,
because God is not mentioned in the
constitution itself,
a controversial thing in it's day by the
way actually God has mentioned,
but in a very insignificant way that the
constitution is a Godfrey document and
because it's a Godfrey document,
it protects your expression of religious
face because it means the government has
no say in who and what you believe or
why.
If the constitution said,
mentioned God and Jesus,
well,
there it is.
There's Christianity built into the
fabric of the country and if you want to
be some other religion,
you're gonna have a hard time because we
can set laws against it.
This is why so many religiously
persecuted people came to the United
States to escape their country where
they could not practice their religion a
little differently or a lot differently
from what was going on in their homes,
in their homeland.
So the.
Is it a problem though to to call it
truth,
I would rather not call a truth,
but I.
I'm,
I'm a big word guy and I respect what
happens to words.
I don't always like it,
but I respect it and so I'm going to say
there is an objective truth,
which is true whether or not you believe
it.
There's your personal truth,
which is true to you.
Third Truth is a political truth.
Political truth is something that is
true because it has been incessantly
repeated it,
and then you just believe it at that
point on one of those.
Okay.
What's Hillary Clinton's first name?
It's crooked,
or first name is actually hillary.
Okay.
I thought it was crooked Hillary.
This is was incessantly repeated in the
trump campaign and that.
That's an absurd example of it,
but,
but the point is if you keep saying,
if you keep saying that the New York
Times is fake news,
it just keeps saying that eventually
people believe it and it becomes a
political truth because the politicians
repeated it,
so it's a political truth that people
believe it or it's a political truth
because people believe it.
Which one is it?
So again,
you're,
you're trying to,
you trying to preserve the true
fundamental meaning of the word truth
and I've just given up on that.
Jordan Peterson and Sam Harris had
infuriatingly frustrating podcasts where
they went over the meaning of the word
truth for more than an hour.
And I,
like I said,
you can do that.
And philosophers like arguing and
debating the meaning of things.
For me it's harder.
People are using the word.
That's the meaning.
I'm,
I,
I concede that.
Well,
we can see those things.
Why I don't call myself an atheist.
It's why you can look up the dictionary
definition of atheist and it kind of
applies to me,
but what is the definition of atheist in
practice?
It is what leading atheists do and it's
their conduct and their behaviors,
what they say,
and it's,
it's,
it's their attitude that is what an
atheist is today because they're the
most visible exemplars of that word and
most of their conduct either don't agree
with or simply don't engage in.
What don't you agree with?
I don't debate religious people and tell
them they're idiots.
I don't know.
That doesn't work.
It's whether or not it works.
I just not.
It's not in me to do that.
I don't purge myself of words that have
religious foundations in them.
I once in my facebook,
I had a friend going up in orbit to
repair the Hubble Telescope,
one of the astronauts and I said,
uh,
Godspeed.
And then I gave the astronauts name
people wrote in,
in the threads that I thought you were
an atheist.
How could you say Godspeed and atheist
got angry with me and I said,
okay.
First of all,
this phrase is deeply historical in the
space program.
When John Glenn was launched,
the headline was Godspeed John Glenn.
Every mission where we send human beings
into space somewhere,
there's that reference in the NASA fancy
word means I'll tell you,
I'll tell you what it means.
Please do.
Okay,
so.
Oh,
by the way,
I'll get to that in just one minute.
The atheist who are arguing that I was
using Godspeed as a phrase,
they all have used the phrase goodbye.
Haven't they see you later?
Goodbye.
What does that word come from?
It's from God.
Be With you.
It's a contraction of those three words.
Oh,
and why would you say this?
You would say this to someone leaving
the city wall where it's dangerous.
Okay.
Back when you had city states,
you're going to you.
You're a good God,
be with you to bring protection for you.
Between one city,
one in crowds.
Look out for you.
So now what is the source of danger?
If you're going to space,
it's not alien space muggers.
It is the fact that you space marauders.
It's the fact that you have high speed
and high speed is the source of
essentially any death of anything that's
in motion.
If you were a part of that,
I'm a disaster.
So Godspeed is like a space equivalent
to God be with you.
Is that really the origin?
I'm just saying.
What did they say that before there were
space travel.
Did they say Godspeed?
I don't know the actual origin of space.
Travel of the term.
Uh,
I don't know how far back it goes,
but I do know it became common after
John Glenn because they're not going to
say it to Yuri Gagarin because they were
there all atheists in,
in the Soviet Union,
but here in America,
in America,
Godspeed John Glenn and I respect that
tradition.
And so I said that and then they jumped.
So if atheist or jumping on me for
having said that,
clearly I'm not an atheist and asked me
my favorite Broadway musical of all
time.
What's your favorite?
Jesus Christ superstar.
So,
and I,
and I still use BC and add in my
writings.
Okay.
I still don't use bce.
I don't use VC.
Alright.
Oh see even you copying the Tude right
there,
right?
I saw your faith.
You got the camera.
Do you see as interesting.
It's interesting,
I'll tell you why.
Okay.
First of all,
it doesn't make any sense.
The current era,
2000 years ago,
I'm good at telling you.
So Bca,
as you know,
stands for before common era and ce
stands for common era.
So this is d irreligious of filing a,
D and B NBC.
Yet,
and of course they referenced the same
calendar.
Okay,
well who invented the calendar?
We all currently use in modern society.
It's called the Gregorian calendar.
It was invented by the Catholic church
by Jesuit priests in the 15 eighties,
assigned by Pope Gregory to fix the
problems in the calendar because I'm
sorry,
I'm screaming at you here.
You can scream.
Okay,
crazy.
I got to calm down.
I'll bring him coffee.
The Julian calendar put forth in ancient
Rome had one modification to previous
calendar.
It had a leap day.
Okay.
It had to leap day and okay.
Leap Day is how often?
Every four years.
This was good because what are we trying
to track?
We're trying to.
Earth goes around the sun and so we say,
all right,
how long does that take?
Well,
it takes a year,
but it turns out we're not actually
tracking how long it takes earth to go
around the sun would tracking how long
it takes earth to repeat its seasons and
the repeat the year that corresponds to
our seasons is slightly different from
the year that corresponds to how long it
takes to go around the sun,
slightly different,
and that difference was not recognized
in the early calendars and that
difference accumulated so that by the
year 15,
84,
the vernal equinox,
the first day of spring,
did not occur on March 20.
First it occurred on March 10th.
It shifted from the calendar date.
That's what happens if you don't match
the cycles of things.
And the pope said,
we're not having any of this,
especially since Easter might land on
Passover and we're trying to distinguish
ourselves mightily from the Jews.
So let's fix this.
The Jesuit priests got to study this.
They looked at the cycles of the
heavens,
the sun,
the moon,
the stars,
and they came up with a new calendar,
the Gregorian calendar,
a modification to the Julian calendar.
You know,
what they have to do to invoke at that,
to take 10 days out of the calendar to,
to jumpstart,
to put,
uh,
the first day of Spring Back on March
21st.
And this happened in October 15,
84.
Why has there been 10 days out of the
calendar that.
So now how much rent do you pay?
They had to like,
invent amortized rent.
Yeah,
because you're going to pay for three
weeks and you know,
20 days instead of 30 that they have to
figure that out.
Okay.
Point is this was hard earned and the
whole world uses this calendar.
It is the most accurate calendar ever
devised.
Yes.
I'll tell you what.
Okay.
You asked.
So watch what happens.
The leap day overcorrected the calendar.
It overcorrected overcorrect yes.
Yes.
So you need to leave here.
So No.
So the leaf days,
every four years,
that one day,
every four years was slowly putting too
many days into the moments into the
year.
Okay.
The Gregorian calendar figured this out
and he didn't put 10 extra days since
the Julian calendar to the Gregorian
count.
Ten extra days.
First Jumpstart,
get rid of the 10 days,
now everything's lined up again.
Okay.
Now how do you prevent this from
happening again?
Because it overcorrect how long do you
have to wait to remove a leap day that
you would otherwise put in?
Okay,
okay.
That's every hundred years.
Oh,
so every hundred years.
That would be a leap day.
You remove the leap day.
Now it turns out that under corrects it
by an even smaller amount.
Okay.
So how long do you have to wait before
you have to put a leap day back in every
400 years.
Oh God.
So the year 2000 was a century year,
which normally would not have a leap
day,
except it's a century year.
Evenly divisible by 400.
So they put the leap day back in and
everybody on February,
almost everybody,
everybody except the astronomers on
February 29th in the year 2000 set.
It's just a leap year because it's
divisible by four.
No,
it is a rarely.
Pierre is a century year divisible by
four.
That corrects it back and so now you
have a stable calendar for tens of
thousands of years.
I got to give props to the Jesuit
priest.
I'm not going to say no.
I'm taking the Christianity out of this
reference because they figured out the
calendar that we all use and it's a
fucking awesome count.
Sorry to drop an F bomb.
But I had so I'm not just because some
atheist are telling me that God had
everything in the universe that to.
I'm not.
I'm not doing that.
I'm going to say they came up with this
calendar for the reasons were because
they didn't want to confuse it.
With Passover.
The motivation is whatever it is,
but the science is is good and so there
it is.
So intercessory to war,
where we go back many centuries,
the editor said,
well,
we should use bcg because there's a
liberal forward.
I'd say I am not using BC and see get.
And by the way there was no year zero.
You know why there's no year zero?
Because the Romans came up with the
calendar and they counted using Roman
numerals.
Roman numerals don't have a zero.
It was not yet invented.
They didn't have a zero.
No.
So it went from one BC to add one BC
before Christ and his anno Domini in
Latin,
the year of our Lord.
Wow.
Now,
of course in,
in Islam and in China,
and in a and Hebrew cultures,
uh,
Israel in particular,
they have access to the Chinese
calendar.
The Muslim calendar,
Muslim of course,
dates to Mohammed Chinese calendar dates
to actually a planetary alignment in
4,700
BC.
They don't,
they use a different system where they
use a different system.
That's fine.
And the Hebrew calendar dates too,
like the beginning of the universe as
interpreted in the,
in the Torah.
So they have access to those.
But when the conducting international
business,
we just simply use the Gregorian
calendar,
just get over it,
but use it in China.
Do they use it constantly and
consistently or do they alternate
between the Gregorian calendar and
something else?
I don't.
I'm not a Chinese expert,
but from what I know of China and my
friends and colleagues that for
conducting business,
the world's business is conducted in on
the Gregorian calendar with a 12 month
calendar with the,
with the year as referenced by everybody
else and does it have to be done that
way in terms of like is there.
Has anyone ever done a study on possibly
creating a more effective,
more accurate calendar?
It doesn't invoke leap years and the
problem is the length of the day does
not cut evenly to the time it takes
earth to go around the sun,
so they'll always be fractions of days
that you're accumulating and now what do
you do with them?
You wait until your accumulated day and
you put it in or take it out.
What did the mind.
This is not this lunar cycle calendar,
but it was an accountant who is based on
Venus and so yeah,
that a really good calendar.
It was overstated that it was like
really accurate calendar.
Overstate,
overstate.
It was good.
Better than anything that came before
it.
Not as good as the.
No,
no,
no.
It's good.
Green County people love old shit
though.
They do and they want to believe that,
especially people who,
you know,
want to believe the people 5,000
years ago somehow knew more about the
university that we do to just know why.
Is that why they wanted to believe that?
I think,
I don't know.
For me,
that's one of the great puzzles of,
of life.
Why do people want to believe that the
Egyptian somehow had some access to the
universe?
Well,
they knew some money.
They cool.
They definitely knew how to some
incredible shit horse,
but that,
that I don't want to take that away from
him.
Doesn't the physical,
just the presence of these incredible
buildings leave the possibility that
maybe they had some knowledge that we
lost.
Lost knowledge is a real thing.
I don't want to belittle or diminish the
significance of real knowledge.
We forgot how to draw in perspective.
You know,
from ancient times had to be
rediscovered in the,
as I understand from the artists had to
be rediscovered in the renaissance.
Uh,
the archway,
the Roman arch had to sort of be
rediscovered.
Okay.
So,
yes.
Yes,
you can lose knowledge,
but if you look at the knowledge we have
gleaned using the methods and modern
methods and tools of science that go far
beyond our five senses in our access to
the world to say that somehow they knew
something that we don't using our tools.
That's just false.
Sorry.
That's just.
It's just not possible,
but we know the physiological limits of
your ability to know what's going on
around you and then people say,
Oh,
I have a sixth sense fine,
but as a scientist I have dozens of
senses.
Okay.
I can measure things that your five
senses can't.
I can measure the magnetic field around
you,
the electromagnetic field,
how much microwaves are coursing through
your body.
Now we have no sensors for this.
I can see auras.
Fine.
I can see other things that are
affecting your body.
Now I can tell you if ionizing radiation
is passing through you,
I've geiger counters that can do that.
You can't.
Oh,
you'll find that you will eventually
learn whether you were exposed to
ionizing radiation because you're.
You'll get cancer of your organs and
your limbs fall off.
All right.
I can see that we know far more today
perhaps at any.
No,
not even perhaps than at any other time
in conceivable history.
Yes,
but it is possible that they knew some
things like how to build a pyramid.
Yes.
That we really just don't understand
today.
I don't know what it means to not
understand how to build a pyramid.
Today we,
we have,
we have 150 story building,
so we are thinking about pyramid stuff.
I can tell you this.
Do you know whether it's the first thing
that was built by humans ever?
No.
The only part of the sentence.
I love your enthusiasm.
My sentence only barely came out of my
mouth.
The tallest thing humans built after the
pyramids.
I think it's a building in Dubai.
No.
So in other words,
tell this thing after the pyramids.
Oh,
right.
After w.
What is the next hottest thing we built?
Stable structure after the pyramids.
What?
The Eiffel Tower?
Yes.
18.
Whatever.
The 89.
18,
Saturday,
late 18 hundreds in Paris.
The Eiffel Tower.
Huh?
That was the first stable structure we
built as a civilization that was taller
than the pyramids,
so the Egyptians knew how to.
They knew architecture.
They knew no one's taken that away from
them,
but to claim they have some secret
knowledge of the functionings of the
universe.
No,
no.
Well people love saying that kind of
stuff.
Yeah,
it makes for great tv,
but the fact that they didn't have steel
and the fact that we're dealing with at
the very,
very most recent 2,500
BC and they built.
You just have to be more ingenious,
more innovative than we otherwise would
have to be.
Yeah,
and how do you move the blocks?
How they make stone Henge?
Those rocks are nowhere in the region.
They were carted from sub with.
They found a place where those rocks
were a would have been mined,
removed,
and yeah,
those are some big ass rocks.
Yeah.
As are the ones that's not less
impressive because they're just big.
Like what the.
The thing about the pyramids,
it's so impressive as the precision and
the sheer numbers.
2 million I best 600,000
stones.
Our best understanding of Stonehenge is
that it's a functioning observatory that
can actually predict eclipses.
So do I go,
I just got to bitch slap.
They're not impressive,
impressive lined with the summer
solstice,
but they have their holes that are not
stones,
but they're 56 holes,
which is three times the Cerros,
which is the cycle of eclipses of the
matching of the orbits of the Sun and
the moon in the sky.
The pants or the sun and the moon in the
sky and when they match up,
you get into clips.
Is there is an eclipse observatory guy
named.
That's absolutely what it is.
There's a book published and in the 19
seventies by guy named David Dawkins,
Richard Dawkins was another one of these
hawkings written Richard Hawkins,
Richard Hawkins,
hawking,
hawking hockings.
Damn what I'm doing.
Damn well.
We've got our top crack researchers here
just to look up.
The title of his book was Stonehenge
decoded.
Just look up the title of that book.
Anyhow,
uh,
it's highly convincing and we all were
all there with it.
There's no,
it's essentially just a study of the
position of the stones in relationship
to the where the.
Okay.
Gerald,
Gerald Hawkins.
Thank you.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Stonehenge decoded.
So he,
I visited Stonehenge as a kid at age 15
on an expedition and he was expedition
head.
Oh Wow.
So how lucky for you.
Yeah,
it was,
it was good.
And that stuck with me,
which is why I named this phenomenon in
Manhattan where the sun sets along the
stress on your instagram.
Yeah.
So,
so I named that Manhattan Henge sort of
hearkening back to my early days
thinking about the alignment of the sun
and structures that we might build
because so twice a year for those
viewers or listeners who don't know
twice a year to Manhattan street grid,
which is not perfectly aligned north
south,
that Manhattan Street Grid,
uh,
will the sun will set exactly on the
grid and in grid and what's up there.
Now,
that image,
what's not obvious is that picture is
taken along a street that is itself
three miles long.
And then you're crossing a,
uh,
the Hudson River and then there's New
Jersey on the other side,
so people try to zoom in on it.
But really what you really should do is
zoom out from it and then you get the
vanishing point on itself.
All those are zoomed,
zoomed in.
Um,
let's go to.
Yeah,
that one looks more like,
like my photo.
I go back to that other one.
Yeah.
See,
so,
so that's on 34th street,
the one you see now.
And then you get this sparkling effect
that happens twice a year.
That sort of crazy wild light effect.
Yes.
It looks photoshop dolls.
Yeah.
Good.
There's an image on his instagram that
is linked on my instagram,
the most recent photo.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh,
there's you with the sound selfish.
So come on down the Afro though.
Yeah,
that's wrong.
That was my first cell phone.
I was a 14 for.
Let me see.
It was 19,
probably 1974.
Wow.
So I would have been 15.
I think I've been 14 or 15 year.
Path of curiosity was set back.
It goes back very early,
right?
Uh,
but that's not the one we're looking for
here.
Let's go on that one.
Thinking it is.
So that is another one where the guys go
back to all of them into rivers.
Wild.
Zoom back out to you see all the
pictures.
They're like,
go to the bottom left.
There you go.
Okay.
That might be the first ever Manhattan
Henge photo out from A.
I took that too.
And it got published in 2002 before
September 11th.
This is July.
I took it before September 11th,
right,
right.
And then I had a means to publish it and
right then the notice that it's a green
light and traffic is ready to knock me
over.
So no one is in the streets doing this,
but now are tens of thousands of people
that pour into the streets on these
days.
We post what day you're getting
Manhattan hinge from the American Museum
of natural history.
My Day job.
And then that goes out.
The press gets it and tens of thousands
of people spilling into the street
blocking traffic.
And if you think of all the ways traffic
gets blocked in your day.
Yeah,
is all it was too many of
them.
You by yourself.
It's interesting.
It's great.
Yeah.
So that's what it has become.
Holding up phones and it's all because I
went to stonehenge.
Yeah.
So it's a,
it's also a,
an observatory.
Was it you that name?
This damn check you out coins.
Coins.
I say coin minted Manhattan hinge
because the buildings are like hinges.
The hinges of stone as a vertical stone
is a vertical structure.
And if you made a stone,
it's a stone henge why isn't it possible
to construct a calendar that doesn't
have leap years?
What you would have to do,
you could do it,
but what would happen is it means you
care more about the year than you do
about the day.
So what would happen is you would
celebrate the new year at like three in
the afternoon.
Uh,
right.
And then the next year you'd celebrate
it at like 12 minutes after three in the
afternoon and then 20 minutes you would,
you would,
it would sort of move through your
calendar and then that means you cared
more about the year that you care more.
About the two,
I say that right.
You,
we always want to celebrate new year's
on midnight.
And by the way,
New Year's is celebrated in 24 time
zones.
Not all at the same time.
So it's interesting.
Everyone thinks of that as a moment yet.
It's really a calendar event.
It's a talk event.
It's celebrated over 24 hours.
Yeah.
If you're in Thailand,
it's 14 hours difference.
So therefore,
if you were to do an astrophysical
physically,
you would know the exact moment where we
returned in our orbit and everybody
would celebrate that instant in.
That would be.
So then the whole world was celebrate
the new year at the same time.
That means you value it differently.
It's not a midnight celebration.
It's a,
you could do that.
I can.
Less so celestial.
Yeah.
Huh.
So that would be the only way.
Yeah,
that's the only way [inaudible] a day
doesn't cut evenly into the year that
those two have nothing to do with one
another.
There's no reason why that would have.
So we,
we,
um,
so in other words,
let me say it another way,
just because you're looking like you're
like,
you're,
you're looking off in space here.
So there's new year's.
Okay,
let's count 365 days when we do that.
We are not at the same place we were
when we left.
Celebrated New Year's Day,
New Year's Eve.
Okay.
We're not at the same place in our
orbit.
A revolution around.
You rotate on an axis.
You revolve around something else.
Since I was two words,
how you use those two words.
So we're not in the same place,
but we celebrate new year's anyway.
Well,
when will we be in the same place?
A quarter of a day later.
Six hours.
So we would celebrate the next new year
at 6:00
AM.
Nobody's willing to do that.
That was really the end of the next new
year at noon,
the next few year at six PM.
And then the next few years kind of
aligns back again.
Well that's the leap day.
That's the fourth year we have put in.
Oh See.
So it's our love of the day.
Yes.
That keeps us fucked up with the world
when it comes to the year.
Yeah,
yeah.
Wow.
You pick one and then that's how.
That's how you do it and what do the
minds based it on the moon?
Right.
I didn't get a cycle.
I didn't study their calendar as deeply
as I should have and wanted to.
Especially back in 2012 and everyone
said,
oh,
the Mayan calendar runs out,
so therefore that's the end of the
world.
I was thinking,
I was thinking it was the end of the war
because the mindsets are the mindsets.
That was back when.
You know,
before that had happened,
it was George Bush was president in 2007
and everybody was thinking,
Jesus,
this is.
This is going to be the end of the.
So what?
So every decade there's somebody
predicting the end of the world.
Sure.
I'm actually quite entertained by this
exercise.
Do you remember when they had billboards
all around la?
Just a few years that that's a different
end of the world.
That's a guy with a radio podcast church
there,
and then the underworld didn't come and
so they pushed it forward.
So that's,
it's entertaining.
We live in a free country.
It's evidenced that we live in a free
country where freedom of speech is
protected and you can practice any
religion you want,
right?
That's a.
and uh,
they didn't learn much science in
school.
That's a part of it.
That's part of the fact that you have
this in our world.
I don't mind it actually.
I find it entertaining,
but it becomes an issue if people such
as that gain power over legislation over
the rest of us,
because this would count this as a
personal belief.
It's your personal belief.
The world is going to end on October
19th in the year.
That's your,
you,
you're fine.
Right?
But if you now create laws that require,
I go with that.
You just impose your personal belief on
me.
And your personal belief is not true for
everyone.
It's only true for you.
Yeah,
that's a problem.
Right?
And an objective truth is true for
everyone.
So if you're gonna have,
if you're going to have governance,
you're going to want a base governance
on what is objectively true because it
would apply to everyone the independent
of your belief system.
Yeah,
I agree with that.
And by the way,
there are.
There are.
There are things that we're not sure are
true yet that we're still researching.
That's not what I'm talking about as an
as an objective truth check.
Your truth had been verified by multiple
scientific studies,
not just one study.
This was the problem with the
cholesterol study.
This is a cholesterol study that said
everybody on the course to drop their
cholesterol levels.
Okay,
saying it would be good for your heart
and all the rest of this,
because a series of countries were
studied where they have longevity and
low heart,
low heart disease and low cholesterol
intake.
That study happened to leave out France.
It happened.
It just wasn't in the study and a couple
of other places that have high
cholesterol intake but don't have higher
heart disease.
So that study was flawed,
but it was hard to replicate it because
it went over many years and it was
thousands of people and so everyone just
jumped on it.
You don't have a scientific truth and
this.
This is a general problem with medical
results because the press is waiting at
the,
at the,
at the Journal Editors Office,
Oh,
here's a new study that shows that this
gives you cancer.
Oh,
that must be true.
And outcomes the headline,
because you want to be the first to
report it,
and then that gets emblazoned in
people's heads and not everyone reads
the followup.
No one could duplicate that study,
no one.
So there's a flaw.
We don't even know what the flaw is.
We know that no one else could get those
results.
So it goes in the dustbin of scientific
research.
Most research in any journal of the
moment will ultimately shown to be
wrong.
That's the bleeding edge of science.
It's a.
it's a great place to be because you're
in the.
You're in the trenches and you don't
know what is true.
You can't look up in the back of the
book what the answer is to double check.
You don't even know what the question is
to ask half the time.
Oh,
but that's very frustrating for people
that don't get it.
Correct,
but it's exciting.
It's exciting for the scientists.
It's exciting to knowledge period that's
constantly expanding and growing,
but it's a very frustrating for people
that really don't have the time and you
know,
maybe he did get some outdated nutrition
knowledge or they need an answer,
right?
No,
they need an answer,
right?
Yeah.
Right now.
And religion in many ways gives you
answers right now.
Yeah.
Without the need to sort of have to
research it or to go on the frontier.
The lack of education and the lack of
the lack of curiosity about it.
It's one of the scariest things about
new generations of kids.
Right?
Like when the new generations are coming
up,
if they know less than the generation
before,
that's when we really start to freak
out.
That would be a problem.
Although I have good confidence in the
30 and under gender because that
millennial,
I will have to be.
I think millennials have only ever known
the Internet and devices.
So what would they say?
Recent,
but my son is a millennial and he's
like,
my kids are millennials,
so they're twentyish.
So 30 is a little old,
so 25 and under I think are the
millennials.
Yeah.
But 30 when they were 10,
the Internet was around.
I know,
but they need a different marketing
terms so you can market to them
differently.
Yeah.
So to me,
I would put them in the same bin just as
you were thinking there,
but,
but they,
they have a different relationship to
science and technology.
Of course they're not,
they don't fear the science or the
technology.
They embrace it because it has shaped
the civilization that is enabled their
social life.
It has been through this.
Like one of the things that I tweeted,
I think it was from scientific American
yesterday,
maybe it was yesterday,
that,
uh,
it's a little bit misleading,
but one of the things they said is only
64 percent of millennials have a strong
belief.
These things,
these coasters are terrible.
They look great,
but then things stick to the made of
metal.
A metal coaster.
Yeah.
What the hell is that?
Sticks?
Yeah.
That's the issue sticks when it gets
moisture.
You know about this,
where you flip this over and tip it
over.
And then what happened on that?
Never do that.
What?
Yeah.
Oh,
because of the pressure.
The air pressure.
It is okay,
but don't do it.
I don't trust your science.
Your objective truth is 64 percent of
millennials are not,
uh,
or only 64 percent are convinced that
the world is a ball.
The world is a circle.
That.
What is it?
Is Fear.
Roid?
Is that what it's called?
Oh,
mean,
I'd like to see how that question was
asked.
Because if they know that we are ablate
and the thing is asking,
is Earth a ball?
They'll say,
no,
we're going blatant ball or a slightly
wider below the equator than,
uh,
than at the equator.
So we're a pear shaped,
oblate spheroid,
but it's not a pair that you would find
normally if you found that period.
But like this is fucking pair that
shaped like a ball.
So the,
these distinctions,
these differences in measurements are so
small that if you found it on the
ground,
you would say there is a perfect sphere.
Right.
Let me tell you how,
how good a sphere it is.
All right.
Do you ever see the schoolroom Globes
that the geographic Globes and you rub
your finger over in Nepal and you get
the.
Yeah.
And you get the rockies.
Oh,
that is a gross exaggeration of reality.
Yes.
Do you realize if you took earth with
all of its mountains,
valleys,
and hills and rep and shrunk it down to
the size of a cue ball,
it will be smoother than any qubole
ball.
Every machine?
Yes.
Think about it.
Think about this job.
Really chill.
Listen to me.
You Ready?
Okay.
Uh,
do you know the deepest part of Earth's
crust?
No.
The Marianas trench off the coast of the
Philippines in the Pacific Ocean.
That's the deepest,
deepest part goes six miles down.
Okay.
Oh,
okay.
So.
Okay.
I was thinking of the depth.
Sorry.
No,
no,
no.
Just access to the deepest part of verse
crest.
The lowest point on her surface.
The Marianas trench right off the coast
of the Philippines.
The highest point on earth surface.
The tip of a k,
one k,
one or k two,
which is Japan.
I think it's k one.
Why would you name the tallest peak?
K Two.
It's good to point.
I'm just,
I'm not a mountain climber,
but I'm,
I'm just thinking.
Okay.
With.
It's the Himalayan mountains in Nepal.
Okay.
Isn't it in Nepal?
I think it is.
Yeah.
Okay.
So now let's say how high up is that was
28,000
feet,
so it's like five miles up.
Okay.
Right.
The distance between the lowest point on
earth surface and the highest point on
earth surface is 11 miles.
That's here to the comedy store.
That is less than the length of
Manhattan.
Oh yeah.
We are 8,000
miles in diameter.
And those two points are very far
separated from one another.
If you are cosmic giant and you came up
to earth and you rub your finger over
earth's surface,
it would feel as smooth as a cue ball to
you.
Wow.
In fact,
in this,
in this book,
I have a whole chapter called on being
round,
which is all about.
This is all about our perception of what
is round and what is not.
I had asked you to debate one of them
flat earth guys.
No,
I don't.
I can't.
I know.
We talked about it and we're gonna have
them on skype.
Not what we do is,
and I think this is a diabolical plot so
that the next time we can ship people en
mass into orbit,
they all want to be the first in line
because they know we're going to send
them.
So if they can see the round earth,
they're going to be the first ones in
space just so they can stop annoying the
rest of.
I don't think you're correct.
I think you're correct,
but everything's a diabolical plot.
I do have people that have met that
don't believe because they.
The problem with youtube videos is that
it's a problem with a lot of things,
but one of the things about being
unchecked,
why you are discussing things is you can
say things,
you can use,
big words,
you can sound articulate and smooth and
you can do it and a very professional
looking manner or do it passionately,
passionately,
convincingly charismatically and you
your unchecked,
but if you did that in front of an
expert and you showed them that along
the way,
they go,
stop.
That's not true.
Stop.
That's not how it works.
Let me show you why this is incorrect.
Let me show you how you could prove that
this is incorrect or objective truths,
but this is not happening to render your
argument invalid so people don't have
any education and then they watch one of
these youtube clips.
They start actually believing that this
stuff makes sense because it's unchecked
and I would say it's not about whether
they've had education.
It's about whether the education they
had teaches them skepticism of
information and teach them how to
inquire.
You realize it's just as intellectually
lazy to believe everything you see as it
is to deny everything you see.
Yes.
Why should someone know automatically
that earth isn't flat yet?
I tell them in the next breath that the
entire universe was once a small as a
marble,
right?
Both of those sound equally preposterous
except one has evidence to back it and
the other does not and very strong
scientific theoretical and experimental
underpinnings.
So when you are trained to inquire,
you don't either believe everything
outright or reject everything outright.
You're trained to ask questions.
You trained to probe deeper than the
layer of information that comes to you.
That's what should be taught in school
and it's not you.
They give you a book and say,
learn this and you'll get tested on it,
and then when you're done,
learn this isn't also there's a problem
with being inexorably connected to your
first belief to you.
When you have an idea and it's in your
head,
it's very difficult for people to shake
that idea and they start arguing that
idea.
That idea becomes a part of their
identity and they dig their heels in
deeper when an opposing view is
presented to they connect themselves to
these ideas.
It is who they are.
Right?
Right.
And so I try not to base my character
profile on something that is not yet
verified as objective truth,
and that's a very good thing to do.
It's one of the reasons why I don't have
tattoos on my body and stretching my
face.
Go on.
Uh,
one of the reasons is there's nothing I
am so sure about that.
I want to put it indelibly on my skin
with no,
no,
not.
Let me say it differently.
There's nothing I value in my mind,
body,
and soul.
So much in this moment that I want to
indelibly etched it on my skin because I
want to leave room for me to have a
possibly more enlightening thought later
that would override whatever was my
decision in that moment.
And since I count myself among the
lifelong learners,
I'm learning stuff all the time.
They say,
wow,
that's good.
I didn't know that.
That's even better.
What's something you've learned
recently?
You went,
ah,
okay.
Let me,
let me think.
Uh Hm.
Okay.
Here's something I learned recently.
I think I knew this when I was a kid,
but if you're playing basketball and
you're shooting,
okay,
and you say,
oh,
that didn't go in.
Oh my gosh.
Well,
you know,
the rim.
They should maybe make the room a little
bigger.
Iq score more often.
Do you realize two basketballs can fit
exactly side by side through the opening
of a basketball hoop.
Really?
Yes.
I guess it makes sense to basketballs.
Tough squeeze.
No,
it's not a cosmically mind blowing
moment,
but that gives you perspective.
Next time you watch a basketball game,
it's how these guys can fly from the,
from the foul line in a,
in a,
an airborne slam dunk and not miss
because the area of this opening is four
times.
You do the math.
It's four times as large as the ball
itself,
right?
Because of the different positions that
could be in multiple positions and they
can do it,
so it's not that that's easy to
accomplish,
but knowing this,
you realize how much easier it is to
score.
Then you might have otherwise thought,
I wonder if basketball,
so that was a recent.
That was a recent revelation.
That's a good revelation.
Yeah.
I wonder if basketball players
occasionally practice with a smaller
hole.
I think about this all the time.
I said if I was a basketball player,
you don't want to practice with a
heavier ball saying yes because that
then you would.
That would throw you off your.
Your practice in a bigger ball.
They use the bigger ball as well.
We use the ball sometimes.
It's almost as big as,
wait a minute.
Is it heavier?
No,
no,
no.
You don't.
No,
you don't use a bigger bowl.
It's a thing that I did a long time ago.
I bet they still don't.
They no longer do it because then your
grip is different.
The grip of matters.
Where are your two hands go and what you
want to do it.
You use a smaller room and in baseball
you throw a faster pitch to give you
less reaction time.
That pool table that you like a skinnier
bat.
That pool table is a very small pocket
opening.
Nice.
Four inch pocket opening as opposed to a
five and a half inch.
That's quite a bit different.
You're doing it,
you're doing it.
And uh,
so uh,
I would also,
you know,
growing up,
I played stickball in the street in New
York and so you're using basically a
broom handle and so when the first time
you play baseball officially it's like,
Whoa,
I've got this huge bat.
And so stick ball players tend to
transfer very well to baseball when
you're a kid.
Yeah.
Because your instrument is bigger to
read the talent code.
Daniel coyle's.
No,
I'm one of the interesting parts about
it is Brazilian soccer players,
how good they are and uh,
they,
he attributed it to a different game
that they play with a heavier ball that
they do indoors.
It's a small heavy ball and because they
do it in tight quarters and involves
incredibly fast footwork and movement
and then these guys take that footwork
and movement and it translates amazingly
well to an open soccer field.
I wonder if they calculated that because
what you would do is,
let's say the ball weighs twice as much,
then it would only go half as far when
you kicked it,
so then you make a field half as large.
I don't think they did.
Then you can reproduce almost all of the
dynamics of the soccer game.
I think it was based on just trying to
play a game and like how far are you
going to call it in over?
If it's the boss twice as heavy,
you throw throat half as far the field
has half the size,
right?
Then you have a mini game.
Basically you do it right.
That makes sense that there's a whole
fun exercise you can do,
uh,
playing sports on other planets with
different grounds.
It's very,
very fun thing to do if you're a Dork,
you know,
it's funny.
Occasionally I'll tweet something and
people say Dork and I say,
yeah,
thanks for the compliment.
Okay.
Nerd.
Is he a bad dad used to take dork as
well.
You'd get wedgies to the nerds.
Um,
well the nerds would also be the that
were like,
but now endured is like you can be a
science nerd and people like it.
That's a goal.
Yeah.
I'm an old movie nerd.
You can say that.
Or movie geek.
Yeah.
Taken Dork,
Dork and nerd.
Yeah,
they tell you,
I must,
I must have told you this last time I
was on your show when I was a kid.
I was bigger than other kids.
I was always one of the tallest kids in
the class out of 30.
So I was bigger than others in the day
and I was also physically fit and
physically active,
athletic.
But I was squarely in the Geek camp.
Okay.
I had my slide rule back in the day,
walking down the car door
know you were also wrestling with.
I was captain of my high school
wrestling team,
so I was a geek person who could
actually kick your ass.
Okay.
And I saw how my fellow Geeks,
because that's the community that I
associated with card carrying were
treated by the football quarterback and
the popular kids and the kids who are
all beautiful.
And the ones who,
and I imagined my future as a superhero
defender of the Geeks so that you put up
a little bat,
sigma,
whatever Geeks they gonna put a few
digits of Pi and I come flying in and
there's a Wedgie in progress,
right?
I would just land and I'd grab the bully
and rip them off the encounter.
And I've just saved the day.
This is my superhero.
Is the football players,
right?
No,
always because there's.
I think they're rewarded for violence,
for violence.
They also have brain damage.
We,
as we've come to discover how fucked up
is that you find another high school
kids,
right?
Literally across the board.
The majority of people who play football
have cte right in as far down as seventh
grade.
Yeah.
What you set?
Remind me that's t stands for chronic
traumatic encephalopathy.
C and Sephora,
dot dot,
dot and cephalopathy both say like Mike
Tyson on monotherapy.
So let me tell you that story about
Christopher Columbus.
Please.
So the Dick Story,
I already told you the Dick Story.
Now let me tell you just something else.
Okay?
Okay.
I think him coming to America was the
most significant thing to ever happen in
our species.
Whoa.
Silence.
Not Internet porn.
Porn in another medium.
Right.
Wow.
Yeah,
so yeah,
Internet porn is just a matter of
degree.
Not a matter of yes.
Does it exist or does it not?
Okay.
I think it was the most significant
event to happen in our space.
Kind amazing.
When you stop
and think about the fact that at that
point in time,
other than the native Americans who
lived here who were living a nomadic
tribal existence,
very few people that had the wheel,
that had firearms,
that had all these things that had
already been achieved in the rest of the
world had made their way to this place.
So then watch,
okay,
here's how it worked.
Right?
So you're going to hear.
So I presume that you have some
skepticism of this claim as most people
would,
especially the Columbus haters who are
out there right now.
I don't really have any skepticism about
it to be honest with you.
Let me,
let me describe to you why I think this
was true.
Okay.
And then you can tell me whether you
agree or not.
All right.
Uh,
we're hunter gatherers.
We haven't settled down yet that early
humans.
And we're basically wandering.
We're following the herds.
All right.
And then the ice age hits.
Well,
what is an ice age?
And Ice Age means it is so cold that
when the moisture evaporates from the
oceans,
goes to the clouds,
the clouds go over the land,
it doesn't rain,
it snows,
and the snow falls and then it stays.
So the water that had lifted up from the
ocean does not return to the ocean.
It accumulates on the land.
And this accumulation,
when it's significant and sustained,
we call glaciers.
Glaciers is not itself a snowfall.
It is compressed snow.
It's basically changed state into this,
this ice river that flows very slowly
back to the ocean,
but the oceans are getting drained
faster than they're getting replenished.
So during the ice age,
the ocean levels dropped.
Exposing the Bering Strait Land Bridge
between Asia and what is now Alaska.
Basically North America,
our ancestors who come out of Africa go
into Europe.
Some state others kept wandering,
some stayed low above the Mediterranean.
Others went high,
they populate Asia,
they keep walking because there's land
bridge there.
They don't even know it's a bridge.
It's just more land,
so they walk and they enter North
America and from there there's kind of
only way you can go with south.
At that point,
the weather gets a little better.
The Ice Age ends,
the glaciers melt back into the oceans.
The oceans level,
ocean levels rise.
Closing.
The landbridge
stranding a branch of the human species
for 10,000
years.
Those humans who made it across that
landbridge and spread out into North
America,
Central America,
South America have only a few families
as their parent genetic genetic origin.
Okay,
Ollie,
it's like that.
Some research says is like eight family
lineages populated the entire north and
South American continents.
Then the land bridge breaks.
Now you have Europe,
Asia,
Africa,
and North and South America,
and they know nothing of one another.
Two separate branches of the human
species.
The Vikings,
not withstanding,
maybe they found came over.
They didn't.
That even if they did,
their influence was near zero relative
to the Europeans.
So we're talking about influence here.
This is a branch had this continued.
This is how you speciate this is why the
species on Australia,
that's why you have mammals there,
but they have pouches,
right?
No other mammals do that.
They split off and they evolved their
own way.
Okay.
So 10,000
years is not enough to grow three heads
or you know,
12 fingers,
but our species is separate.
Now Columbus crosses the Atlantic,
makes contact with humans.
This is the first time that has happened
in 10,000
years.
We have rejoined two branches of the
human species.
We are now one common genetic group and
that genetic crossbreeding and that
continues to this day we fly to any
corner of the world and mates.
Okay.
And the mating already began
immediately?
Yes.
There were diseases that Columbus
brought to North America.
Much written about that less written is
that he brought syphilis back to Europe,
first cases of syphilis in 14,
92.
Whoa.
And then it skyrocketed from the native
Americans.
What did they have?
No problem with it?
Well,
I don't know the details of how the
physiology of the natives have dealt
with that or whether it mutated and
there may people know that I'm not among
them.
That's fast.
But if just look at,
you look at the graph of syphilis,
syphilis cases in Europe.
It all began in 1492 when he came back.
So what I'm saying is this was a hugely
significant event,
the rejoining of the branches of the
human species.
But yeah,
no,
I would imagine that,
that makes sense.
That is the most important event.
And by the way,
native Americans,
you know,
it's famous,
infamous problem with metabolizing
alcohol.
Okay.
With native Americans,
you know,
what else has that problem?
The Chinese,
they do.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
So it's an Asian issue.
Well,
so who stayed in?
So you look at who populated north and
South America after the,
you know,
before the land bridge,
whoever was right at the edge of Asia,
then the land bridges so,
so,
so Asians and and North American and,
and the natives of north and South
America have more in common with each
other because of this than most other
pairs or groups you might grab around
the world.
But my point is obviously we,
there's a lot to blame Columbus for,
but he just happened to be the guy who
did it first.
Europe was coming to the new world no
matter what,
everybody was trying to find a faster
trade route to the indies.
And so if,
what if it wasn't Columbus,
it would have been arnold mednick,
whatever.
It doesn't matter.
Somebody did that and the rest is,
as they say,
history.
Wow.
So personally I think the most
significant thing to happen in our
species.
Otherwise we'd still be two stranded
branches of humans.
It would be fascinating though,
like Australia stranded to see what
would happen if this has gone on for
hundreds of thousands of years,
have 100,000.
That would have been a different story.
Right,
and your immunities would be different
to your.
Yeah.
Oh,
well that's the big concern about
aliens,
right.
One of the big concerns is that there's
some sort of a virus,
the pickup from somewhere.
I think that's harder to accept.
So for example,
um,
what are the chances that a oak tree
would catch whooping cough?
Not so good.
We're two different species,
so viruses tend to be very species
targeted.
Yeah.
But what about now?
They can't jump species.
Sure.
They can jump species,
but.
So there's a jump mammal to mammal
doesn't vertebrate invertebrate Britain,
but.
So yes,
that can happen,
but the more different the life form is,
it is sensible to suppose that the less
likely you're going to share the same
diseases,
that's all.
But NASA regardless has safeguards in
place in the event that that happens.
So it's a,
it's called a planetary protection
program.
In Ethics Code is a whole division of
Masco.
It's protecting earth from bugs that
could be coming from space on our own
spaceship that we bring back and it
protects destinations from us.
There's a certain sterilization levels
that we invoke the Cassini spacecraft.
We plunged that back into Saturn in its
death.
When we were done with it and ran out of
money.
We're done with it plunged into Saturn
to vaporize.
We didn't leave in an orbit around
Saturn.
Why?
Because it might have crashed into one
of Saturn's moons that might have life
and if someone had sneezed on the
spacecraft before it got launched,
we don't want to contaminate the life
that we are later gonna one day want to
study.
So that's why.
So we plunged it into Saturn.
That's why that is why,
because they were worried about,
let me be in hitting Europa.
Once it's dead and you can't track it or
guide it anymore.
Then it's a.
it's a while.
It's a wildcard.
It might hit a Europa is jupiter and
enceladus.
There are other moons that have sort of
ocean water,
the water worlds basically.
And so the concern is that we would
introduce life.
Suppose we did it crashed and then we go
back later and find life and it has dna
just like here,
but it wasn't our life that we
contaminated with.
Is that what you don't want to confuse
the future science of it.
So that's,
that's the plan.
Can you even watch a science movie like
science fiction movies?
I know he had a real problem with
gravity,
but.
Right.
So let me set the record straight here.
Okay,
let me.
Let me just go on record.
Okay.
I've been deeply misunderstood with my
comments on movies,
deeply misunderstood,
deeply,
and so I've just stopped.
When was the last time you saw a movie
comment in my twitter stream?
They haven't.
You haven't?
I've kind of just stopped.
Wasn't the Matthew mcconahey movie?
Did you comment on that one?
That one.
Oh,
interstellar interstellar.
That's the last one I commented on in a
big way.
Right.
And you're done.
I'm done.
Because people then thought I was just
being nitpicky.
Oh,
D one.
It's not fun going to the movies with
you.
God.
Let that.
Tyson will just say that can never
happen.
And so,
so my intent was my intent did not match
how people received my intent.
My intent is,
here's an observation that I think if
you understood this,
it would enhance your appreciation of
the movie.
Let me give an example.
Please do star wars.
The force awakens they've got was at.
That's the one that introduced a bb
eight.
Okay.
Is that the most recent one?
No,
no,
no.
It's just like for movies ago now,
because I've lost track because there's
another one.
So the one that introduced BBA,
cute.
As cute as ever fell a cute little
fellow.
And in there they have the,
like the,
the updated deathstar.
Right.
Okay.
Remember the old death star?
It has enough power to destroy a planet.
And that's devastating.
This one,
it can suck energy out of a star so that
the star no longer exists.
Then it could take these energy beams
and killed six planets at once.
It's no longer just a one planet killer.
Six or eight,
whatever the number was.
It was like high single digits.
Okay.
Well,
I did the math on this and I tweeted and
I said first,
okay,
if you take all the energy from a star,
you become a star,
but let's know.
Maybe they've got a containment
mechanism.
I'll give it to them.
It is the future after all,
I don't think it's the future,
but will that long time ago in a galaxy
far,
far away.
It's another,
another,
another universe of civilizations.
Okay.
But they have lightspeed and we don't.
So it's the future of our technology.
Even if it's the past of our time.
Ooh,
oh.
So you do the calculation and I forgot
the number,
but I got.
I calculated how much energy is stored
in a star that's enough energy to
explode a thousand planets.
Oh my gosh.
They are underrepresented.
The energy that it sucked out of the
host Atar out of the store.
And I thought this could have been more
bad ass than even they came up with in
this movie.
That is the nature of my comments.
Not Real.
Could this happen?
Could it not happen?
Let me give you a perspective.
Okay,
well wait,
so,
so 20 percent of people just get pissed
off.
Eighty percent really like it and they
want more,
but that 20 percent they,
they cut me no slack and I'm only doing
this for people to enjoy and if I,
if I have that level of hate mail,
I don't need to continue it.
So I just basically stopped.
I just,
I'll have these thoughts to myself,
but I don't have the urge to share them.
I still have the thoughts.
I got to teach you the art of post and
drop.
Okay.
This is what you do.
You post something,
know people are going to get mad.
You drop your phone and you walk away.
You got to learn how to do that,
man.
You can't be reading those fucking
comments.
It's dealing with too many human beings.
No,
I get that.
But,
but you don't because you still changing
your behaviors.
Morons.
Here's my rebuttal,
your rebuttal,
my rebuttal.
Okay.
If you're watching a movie that takes
place in 1958,
it's a period piece and there's a car
from 1960.
Oh yeah,
that'd be crazy.
And someone who's a car expert points
that out and say,
Hey,
he's an expert.
That's pretty good.
Do you complain that the person noticed
that?
No.
You praise their expertise.
I get mad at the movie.
If you get mad at the movie,
if you're watching a Jane Austin period
piece and it's 1870,
whenever they took place and someone
gets out of the carriage with tie dye
bell bottoms,
you would cry foul.
That would take you up.
I'm exaggerating there.
Obviously it could be a top hat instead
of a derby.
He would cry foul.
If you wear a costume designer and we
would all be impressed by that level of
knowledge that you exhibited.
I am bringing a level of science to bear
on a movie that is no different from
anybody else's expertise who is out
there that we have praised for that
invocation.
Yet people are not granting me that
latitude to make those comments.
I don't like these generalizations.
I don't know,
but I don't like you.
You're saying people are not doing this.
No.
A small vocal minority that are assholes
and those are the people that you're
altering your behavior for.
That's what I think is ridiculous about
this because my idols people and enjoy
it.
When are you talking about gravity and
the fact that hair wouldn't do that and
the space stations weren't that close
together and see it in the sky.
My work.
Right?
Right,
but.
But it's assholes.
No,
I my tweets or offerings,
they're not,
but I'm not a problem.
That's the problem.
The only problem is you're reading
responses.
No,
you're doing is wonderful.
One educating people.
Twenty percent freak out is high for the
fuck is 20 percent listening.
Amy.
I'm believe that's numbers here,
man.
I'm when it's five percent.
Then I take notice.
When you say 20 percent like what are
you doing?
Calculations.
You actually do another scan.
100 of them,
20 of them.
That's just run into 20 assholes.
So 20 assholes out of the millions and
millions of people that follow.
You have decided to reach out and and
Louis,
you're altering your behavior for
assholes.
I like those quotes.
I like when you,
when you,
when you break things down,
because I didn't know those things and I
like thinking about like the hair and
gravity.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
a fucking shit be standing straight up
and the only reason why I mentioned
about here,
because every photo of anybody with long
hair wouldn't happen to you,
but anyone was long here in space.
It standing up on edge.
It's a completely obvious thing that was
omitted from the filming of gravity.
Yeah,
but you have to have hair and makeup.
They have to have a reason to exist.
So.
So what I might do,
I might take a poll.
I might put up by my postal service.
I don't want to force feed curiosity.
Have to listen on your feet.
No one else to feed anybody.
Force feeding anything.
You pretty offerings out there,
like you said,
does not force feeding.
You're not knocking on someone's home.
Wake up bitch.
My Shit.
That is true.
I'm not forcing myself on your property.
Do we get it all?
Put the shotgun down.
You're going to hear me talk about your
movie.
This in man.
I said about bb eight.
I said,
first I said bbs way cuter than r two,
d two,
and I use like five a's in the way just
to just to start a fight because that.
That's a fun fight.
Right?
Then I said,
by the way are to a bb eight,
a smooth metal rolling spherical ball
would have skidded uncontrollably on
sand in the whole movie is moving
around.
I'm saying,
right?
Yeah,
it would.
That's why you deflate your touch while
you deflate your tires to drive on sand.
That's correct.
Oh,
you can't.
Have you ever tried riding a bicycle?
And Sandra,
it's impossible to.
Good point.
And imagine that with rubber tires.
Imagine steel tires.
You're not running on a sand dune.
Holy Gosh.
Oh yeah.
One of the hardest things you could do
for talking about getting into shape,
so it will work.
If you have a hard surface just below
it,
a dusting of sand,
then you then you can dig into it and
some resistance to sand then connects to
the hard surface.
So.
So I posted this and people say,
you're ruining the movie for me.
And then people started this assholes
again,
who the.
When you say people,
you just listening to assholes,
smart people going to read that and go,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
this is stupid.
It would roll around and it gives you
that fucking thing track.
But you know,
it's actually happened as a result.
I think I'm getting phone calls from
producers.
Oh,
there's a little bit of science.
We want to make sure that you don't
tweet about it.
You keeping them on point.
As you know,
I might be most famous among in movie
commenting for the final scene in
titanic.
Okay.
If you knew about this,
but what would you say about the
fucking.
So we know where the titanic sank.
The longitude and latitude.
Yes.
We know what time of day.
Oh,
so at the p of v,
the point of view of,
of rose,
and she's looking up deliriously to the
sky.
There's only one sky she should've seen.
And it was the wrong sky.
Not only that,
the left side of the sky there was worse
than it was worse than that.
The left side of this guy was a mirror
reflection of the right side of the sky.
Did you call jeans?
Because I called her,
I didn't know.
Replaced back in 1996.
I saw it when it first came out.
I noticed instantly and because I know
the sky,
this is what I.
Okay,
so no reply.
Five years later I bumped into him at a
meeting a NASA hosted a meeting with
some explorers and some scientists.
I brought it up to him and he says,
well,
at the time I was not overseeing
postproduction and that's when we added
that.
So I'm immaturely wanting them to grovel
at my feet for forgiveness.
I wanted them to,
but that's not what happened.
So then five years after that,
I brought it up again when I bumped into
him and then he said,
you know,
last I checked the titanic,
titanic has earned more than a billion
dollars worldwide.
Imagine how much more it would have
earned if I'd gotten the sky correct.
That's a stupid answer from an asshole.
It was as it should be tweeting,
you know,
so.
So that is an asshole.
And listen,
let's wait.
That's an ego answer,
but it's not the end of the story.
So.
So that was okay.
I have nothing more I can say here
because he's right.
Okay.
No,
he's not.
He's right now.
He made it a lot of money and it
would've made the same amount of money
with the correct.
That's true.
But that's not the point.
But he's crazy fucked up,
bitch.
You fucked up.
Don't say how much money.
A week later I got a phone call so high,
I forgot his name.
Johnson.
Hi John.
How can I help you?
Is this the dot types?
I said yes.
He said I work post production for James
Cameron.
He's producing a director's cut where
he's adding new footage and he tells me
you have a sky he could use.
So this centennial release of titanic
released in April 2012 w dot the w.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Yes.
So how'd you pick up that?
There was a April 2012.
I feel like you and I had this
conversation because we might have,
we might have.
I just put this in context now it's got.
So uh,
so he actually put in.
So he did come through my.
So here's what happened.
Seth Macfarlane calls me up and said,
I'm making a movie about a talking teddy
bear and I need to know the sky over a
town outside of Boston in 1985 on
Christmas eve looking north,
northeast.
You've got a sky.
I say,
I'll get back to you.
Half hour later I sent him the sky.
That was the sky that the kid wished on
to forward where Ted came to life.
Wow.
So Ted had the correct Scott and titanic
did not.
So correcting these Ted one,
titanic zero on that.
Right?
So the point is that people started
thinking about it and I,
the highest compliment I ever got was a
Andy Weir who wrote the Martian.
He said to himself while he was writing
the novel,
he said,
because he's an engineer,
so he has the fluency and he's also
knows how to write a.
he's a write creatively.
He said,
if Tyson we're looking over my shoulder,
what would he,
would he tweet about this or not?
And so that put them on notice to make
sure that his calculations were accurate
and the Martian is one of the most
entertainingly accurate explorations of
how to invoke science to not die that
there ever was.
So for me,
that was a very high compliment and it
was kind of worth it.
All of the naysayers that to know that,
that uh,
Andy,
we're came through on that.
Yeah.
So why stop?
I don't know.
Maybe you.
Maybe I'll change.
I think you need to drop.
Just think about it like this post and
boom,
walk away,
walk away.
Go do something else,
man.
You don't need to look at that shit.
You don't need to look at what people
are going to say.
Make sure that there's no typos.
That's always a struggle.
I'm like,
no.
Yeah,
it is.
Isn't that amazing?
Yeah.
I got fat.
Thumbs.
Me Too.
Um,
I,
I care though.
I'm sure you do.
About what,
how people can think about what I wrote.
If it's a way that I had not considered.
Okay.
I like knowing it.
It makes me a better communicator when
I'm in front of an audience.
I'll know what percent will think one
way versus another and I can modify what
I'm saying to be more precise and to,
as we say,
in physics,
to reduce the impedance between the
signal and the receiver so that there's
a better match between the communicator
and the audience.
I understand that,
but if you surely have told jokes that
people just took the wrong way the right
way,
they just didn't like what I was saying.
Yeah,
but it's surely like you see the word
cock in a response,
you know that person's an asshole,
right?
There's certain things you just see like
your cook,
like,
okay,
I love to listen to anymore.
Now I know what you are full.
Right?
And you see that like you're stoned all
the time staring at the fucking sky
instead of filling the blank.
Those are just assholes.
Well,
I have pretty thick skin,
so it's not that it upsets me.
It's that I'm here to serve you,
not to piss you off when you're not
there to serve as an educator.
There's some people,
I'm an educator there are looking to get
angry.
Maybe I can bring them around,
but you can the arrogance of thinking
that you could fix 30 plus years of
worthless shitbag living with a couple
of tweets and you know,
something,
I don't even want to take you up on that
challenge because you're probably right.
I'm telling you,
you gotta you gotta walk away.
But for most people,
myself included in those,
most people,
I enjoy those tweets.
So I got one something.
Here's one.
So I tweeted something and somebody's
responding to somebody else's tweet
said,
um,
you know,
I don't really like Tyson.
He's such,
he's so pompous.
Okay.
So,
so I tweeted back to that person and I
said,
thanks for your note.
Could you please share with me the
single most pompous thing you've ever
seen me do?
And he wrote back and said,
damn,
you would have to be reading my tweets.
What you got now you put me on the spot.
I can't think of anything right now,
but overall I really like your work.
Keep putting nothing forward.
Yeah,
that happens all the time because people
were just shocked that you respond well.
Well,
but,
but plus there is people can get into a
stereotype mode where there's go that
person is that and therefore everything.
They just decide.
That's the lead.
Decide they decide.
Right?
Right.
There,
you can listen to those people.
Too Smart for this.
People said,
look,
the dude wrote a book called it
astrophysics for people in a hurry.
How pompous is that?
That's not right,
right.
You're a science educator.
I interviewed Onstar talk.
I guess you were one of my guests,
but so too was Katy Perry.
Then you go through.
People got pissed off because they have
nothing to add.
She just popped.
I said she wrote a.
She wrote a song about boning and
Anglian and I wanted to find out what
she was thinking.
Yes.
This yes.
Her Song,
she is a line about it,
which you're making love doing it,
so there's always ways you can fuck
Russell Crowe a few times or what's his
name?
Peter's sorry,
Russell.
I don't yet brand.
What does Russell Peters Russell Recipe.
It is a good friend of mine.
It's like,
Yo,
what the fuck?
Sorry Russell.
I don't keep a log.
I just got back from Italy.
Oh yeah.
I'm very confused.
I'm my brain's zoning.
A little out of it.
It's just completely out of it.
I'm trying to keep you awake for your
brand.
Russell.
She fucked Russell brand.
Say it.
I didn't know.
I didn't take.
I didn't know any of this.
They were married.
I didn't know this.
So he's like an alien is my point.
It's a very odd duck.
Oh,
I see.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a brilliant guy,
but he's,
he's out there and he'd be like one of
those guys that would be in um,
in men in black aliens that they're
tracking to,
to remember that scene in the
headquarters.
There's a big brides were to cover
aliens,
and they're like,
Michael Jackson was there.
People who just do something a little
different about them,
you know?
So there's people that really do believe
that the believed that there's aliens
amongst us again,
and we learned a free country.
I'm fine.
But what happens?
Evidence at some point should matter.
But you,
you find out about like Russian agents
that have been living in New Jersey for
like 30 years.
That's the whole premise of the
Americans,
the Americans.
Yeah.
It's a real story to.
I mean really has happened on multiple
occasions and so they wonder,
well,
if the Russians were wanting to do that,
what are the aliens willing to do?
Yeah.
So just find me one.
Yeah,
maybe there are doing.
Are you open minded to that course?
Oh my gosh.
No.
Who doesn't want to be?
I wish I would love to meet the aliens.
They're going to have technology that we
don't have to compare notes.
I want to.
Oh my gosh.
Do you,
by the way,
in the movie arrival with the.
Which one?
The arthropod.
All this.
And there's two arrivals.
So there's an earlier rather with
Charlie Sheen.
He played an astrophysicist by.
That's a good one too.
So this one,
uh,
it's,
you know,
it's like a Septa puss.
Lands freaky things with speaking inc.
Okay.
Speaking ink.
Right.
SO,
so they sent the physicist and an
anthropologist,
anthropologists a,
a linguist,
and I tweeted,
I said,
you know,
if aliens come,
I would not send a physicist and link in
a linguist.
I would Send it up an astrobiologist and
a cryptographer and but then the
linguists got all upset and they started
piling,
piling the pile pilot.
She's not a linguist.
She was a witch.
If it's,
if you're an anthropological linguist or
are they all are.
But could you just look up the title,
what her profession was?
But anyhow,
so,
so they all piled on,
piled on.
But that's,
that's fine.
I will accept because how many linguists
are ever shown in the film.
So this was their time and the sun is a
big moment so I get it.
That's fine.
But there a couple of things.
So for example,
there it is making these circles and
they're interpreting them but it's
making them on glass.
So how do they know?
We weRen't seeing them.
the mirror image of what he was trying
to communicate that that was not
addressed in the film.
But yeah,
I'd want to meet the alienS as they did
there.
They bought the military of course that
it will be a likely fact,
but because your protection is of
extreme importance,
but here this happens in all scifi
movies.
you go up to this thing and you get
lifted up against the force of gravity.
At that point I would just put down all
my weapons because stuff going on this
way,
beyond your understanding of the laws of
physics,
you know,
it's like pulling out your pistol and
shooting at the spacecraft.
They crossed half the galaxy to,
to come to you.
What are you doing?
They are clearly superior to you in ways
that you don't even know yet.
So just find another way to do.
You're talking rather than sending
bullets there way.
But isn't that always the case in every
film?
I mean,
it's always part of the narrative is
that the primitive people fuck it up for
the advanced civilization that's coming
here to help us or.
Yeah,
it's never been good for the less
technologically advanced civilization
ever,
ever.
and going on right now.
Currently,
by the way,
undiscovered tribes.
Not to sound pluggy,
but this,
one of the profiles here is of captain
cook.
Uh,
just a quick thing.
I visited Hawaii only a couple of times
in my life.
One of the times I saw don ho show.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh,
and he was like,
he only sat down.
He was like big and heavy and old and he
died a couple of decades ago.
But anyhow,
don ho,
he just helps hawaiian stories and one
of them was about captain cook and pete
that some.
Someone asks,
well,
what ever happened to captaIn cook?
You know how he replies?
He says,
nobody's ever seen him.
So people listening,
he's making things like he's picking
things out of his team.
Nobody's ever seen captain cook of late.
So it was.
Rumors are that he was eating by pacific
island natives,
but that happened to a lot of pirates.
So watch what happens.
So the british send captain cook to the
south pacific.
Why will you look at his marching
orders?
It's,
oh,
there Is what's called a transit of
venus that's going to take place visible
only from the south pacific.
This is where earth in our orbit and
venus's in orbit are such that when
venus passes between us and the sun,
it actually is exactly between us and
the sun.
You can watch it,
move the circle,
move across the sun surface,
and did they look at it through a device
to device filters?
We were fine.
okay,
so if you measure that,
you can learn the exact scale of the
solar system.
So you learn deep scientific knowledge
about how far away the planets are and
how far away the sun is from the earth.
It was not known with precision before
that measurement was made.
So captain could goes on this voyage to
do this.
Well,
that's a pretty expensive voyage.
Oh,
I'll wait,
flip over the marching orders.
Oh,
open the envelope.
while you're there,
use these new navigation techniques that
use the sun,
moon and stars and map every coastline
you find and bring that information back
to us.
Within 10 years of captain cook,
navIgating the south pacific as well as
the northern coast of of Australia and
New Zealand.
Within 10 years,
britain took control over those
coastlines became part of the british
empire,
had gemini at its finest on
the premise that he's observing
something about the universe,
but there was a tandem role that he
played.
I did not know they knew that much about
the cycles of the planets that they
could be there.
They knew accurately they could be part
of the motivation.
Part of the motivation of knowing any of
this was navigation around the globe was
navigation.
How are you going to know where you are
on earth?
You can get your latitude.
That's just the altitude or the height
of polaris,
the north star above the horizon and
measure that at night.
You can wait that long.
Where do you know where you are in
longitude?
Ships would,
would be shipwrecked.
Millions of dollars worth of commerce
would be at the bottom of the ocean
because they didn't know where coastline
was.
And the only way you can measure
coastline,
it's if you have good navigational tools
and tactics which involves,
uh,
an accurate chronometer,
a timekeeping device for your pre and
knowing what the sun,
moon and stars are doing in your sky.
So the astronomer In that day was
crucial to the mapping of the earth.
And whose mapping?
Or is it just geologists for fun?
No,
it is nations wielding power over
regions beyond the,
beyond their own coastlines.
And that's.
I have a quote here.
That's where this quote comes from.
I got a guy from 17 whenever I got here,
1757,
James Ferguson,
17,
57.
Here's this quote of all the sciences
cultivated by mankind.
Astronomy is acknowledged to be and
undoubtedly is the most sublime,
the most interesting and the most useful
for by knowledge derived from this
science.
Not only the bulk of the earth is
discovered,
but are very.
Faculties are enlarged with the grandeur
of the idea as it conveys our minds
exalted above their low contracted
prejudice.
If I got a drop of a michael now,
here you go,
boom.
Drop that mic.
so notice he lists mapping the earth
first,
then he talks about how it exalts and
our grander.
So,
uh,
yeah,
it's an exercise in dominance,
in hegemony,
in power under the guise of studying.
Well,
it's not so much,
it's just they co,
they did it together.
If they matter to one another,
another part of it,
part of it.
And they using a sextant for all this
sub sexton help.
There's an octet a little earlier.
Uh,
the and the,
the muslims used an astrolabe okay.
That you'd got,
by the way,
what's the number?
it's a third or two.
I forgot that the fraction around a half
of all stars that have names in the
night sky have arabic names because in
the golden age of islam a thousand years
ago,
navigation was
a big deal.
And they navigated using astrolabes,
which is sort of the,
the,
the islamic counterpart to the sextant
and the [inaudible] that were used.
What does the rest of europe asked her?
Electrolytes.
A cordial.
Oh.
Then they're,
they're works of art.
They're brass,
they're etched.
There was riding,
I'd sell them.
You can buy replica is what?
You're not going to get original fine.
Astrolabe.
Yeah.
What that looks like.
Oh yeah.
So,
uh,
there's,
there's a thing that hangs down.
There are different,
a disc that you can replace depending on
where you are on earth to be,
to know where you are more accurately.
So this is all navigation so that it was
almost like chips for a gps device.
They're gorgeous.
They're completely gorgeous.
Wow.
What the fuck.
And you'd carry them with you on that
somewhere you'd go.
Okay.
Aliens have been.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
If you didn't otherwise know your
history and look at the size of that,
that's about the size of a um,
a heavyweight,
a champion's buckle.
Buckle belt.
Buckle.
is that thing doing?
So,
yeah,
it depends on where you are wondering
when you're saying.
So this is,
we're talking about this was,
you know,
a thousand years ago said you know,
this 700 years ago,
600 years ago,
five or the ottoman empire is spreading
their influence and they've got,
they've got astrolabs.
So this is islam.
You don't even learn about this in
school because you only hear about the
rest of europe,
christian europe.
So this mess.
Incredible looking device.
Yes.
and these are dials that turn,
it looks like under a tattoo.
It doesn't even look like there's a
rhyme or reason to it with all the
clause and everything.
It completely looks like art.
It looks like some bizarre.
Looks like an alien.
Yeah.
So again,
if you're only listening,
just just google astroland astrolabe and
then look at any of them.
That's a primitive and more primitive
one.
They're simpler one.
Um,
and so that's 16.
Oh,
two.
So.
Oh no.
So that one that has the spirit of an
astro lay,
but I don't know that if they would have
called that an astrolabe the others,
they,
they go way back.
And so the,
the most decorated ones are the ones
from the middle east.
Anyhow,
the point is gps is no different from
the navigation tools in,
in,
in concept,
from the navigation tools that captain
cook invoked for britain to then take
control over all the south pacific that
they did.
It is,
where are we and do we know this
information with precision and so,
and what happens if an enemy force takes
out our gps and we have so much
dependent on it,
what are we going to do?
We've got people now worrying about
working on using navigation by pulse.
Ours can't take those out because those
are cosmic.
They're sending highly timed pulses that
reach earth in different places on the
sky and by measuring you
can end the time delay between one and
the other.
You can actually localize yourSelf on
her surface with extremely high
precision and without any use of
satellites.
That's the future of navigation where
you were insulated from a rogue nation
that might want to take out your
satellites hole size pulsars.
And by the way,
the trump space force,
you know the many,
the whole lot of trump haters out there
and,
but if you want to hate trump
rationally,
you want to not hate them no matter what
he said.
You want to evaluate statement by
statement what he says,
right?
That's what you want to do.
He says,
I want a space for us.
Well,
let's think about that.
Okay?
In the Second world war,
there was the air force,
except they were not their own branch.
they were part of the army.
It was called the army air force,
and then we realized that command and
control in the air needs different kinds
of soldiers though because they have to
be pilots.
It's a different kind of decision
making,
different kinds of tactical.
I'm actually actions you would have in
the in the theater of operations and so
it was sensible to spawn off a new
branch of the military called the air
force.
No one today would question whether that
was a good idea.
Today.
You should know that operations in space
in the vacuum of the universe is a
different regime that you're operating
in from moving through the air,
your hardware,
it looks different.
your,
your strategies are different.
Your decision,
your command and control is different,
so it's not a credit.
Just because it came out of trump's
mouth doesn't make it a crazy idea that
you might want a space for us.
In fact,
I had proposed the space for us in 2001
when I was on a commission appointed by
george w dot bush to explore the future
of the United States space.
Aerospace industry.
A commission of 12.
So I put it on the table.
We have air force generals,
they're former members of congress,
people from lockheed martin and people
said,
well,
the air force is currently overseeing
space United States space command,
so everybody was happy with it and so
I'm fine.
I said,
okay,
let's not worry about it if everybody's,
but as if as long as this needs of our
presence in space grows,
but more importantly the size of our
assets,
as long as that continues to grow,
what else would the military do beyond
protecting your borders?
They would protect your assets and our
space.
Assets by day,
day by day are growing by leaps and
bounds.
So as not assets meaning like satellite
satellite station and the value of
those.
It's not just the cost of the satellite
is the value that's at the satellite to
you,
right?
The,
uh,
the military is now creating a whole
other gps system that will be exclusive
to them and then they're going to see
the current gps to an and what have we
done with gps?
This hard earned engineering and physics
and orbital mechanics.
What have we done with the gps?
We now use it to find out who you want
to mate with.
Oh,
someone's in your area.
This is tinder.
This is grinder that says,
show me mateaBle people within 20 square
blocks of where I am.
that's a gps on grindr.
I did look up.
The definition of mate,
mate implies you're making a baby.
Who are you going to have sex with?
Fun.
Yeah.
Yeah,
so so that has a certain economic value
to society and sodas,
uber,
so to all the things that sodas,
ups tracking their trucks so it's not
the cost of the satellites,
the value of the satellite to our
economy.
You'd want that protected.
Make sense?
Is there a space for us currently?
Like is it real?
Are they recruited as United States
space command,
so anybody who was a general,
if we make a space,
they're generals in the air force
overseeing space command,
so if you're going to make a space
force,
you would offload,
you would offload the space activities
of the air force space command to this
us space command primarily to the space
force and then add or subtract from
that.
In whatever way is sensible given the
neat.
If we have a space for it,
you know what?
I want to see what I want them to
protect us from asteroids.
How about that for defense program?
That makes sense.
Okay.
Do you want the government involved in
that?
Shouldn't be someone a little bit more
thorough.
It's not how it works.
It's not scientists you,
you just made you made a blanket
antigovernment decision because you're
just antigovernment guy.
People say,
okay,
so I'm private.
Enterprise is not good at doing
expensive things that have never been
done before.
Right?
Need government money?
Government government does it first.
Okay.
Right.
Then you learn where the hostels are,
where the friendlies are,
where the.
What patent did you need to make this
happen?
then the venture capitalists meeting
about whether I'm going to make a bucket
on it,
has some,
some teeth in it.
They say,
how much will this cost?
Well,
we know because the government did it
and we think we can do it for half that
price.
Is it dangerous?
Yes.
The government did this and they lost
two people,
but we will put protections in so we
won't have that risk.
What is the return on the investment?
So the government got no return because
they didn't.
That wasn't the objective,
but here's how we can bring them.
So I'll do it second.
I want to.
At first,
this is how you get the dutch east India
trading company.
They were not the first europeans to the
new world because where's the edge of
the earth?
Will you find India?
will you?
It's what you don't know any of this.
I'm screaming at you.
Sorry.
You don't know any of this.
Columbus does it first and he can tell
you where there's food and where there's
isn't,
where there isn't and where they want to
kill you.
In where they don't,
then you hand that information to the
market,
to the mercantilists and they make a
book after the fact.
So they come in,
they come in,
yeah,
that's how you do it.
That's how modern airplanes came about.
People were making planes in their
garage.
The government said this could be a cool
thing.
Let's pay them and have them compete to
carry airmail new kind of mail mail
delivered by air.
Oh,
that's cool.
So now I make an airplane because I want
their contract.
You say,
no,
you want the contract.
You make an airplane.
That ca has more cargo,
a better engine.
You're cleverer now.
You just took the contract from me.
Now I make a bigger airplane because I
said,
oh,
I see what he did there,
but now I can improve on that.
No,
wait a minute.
I don't need to carry mail.
I can carry people.
And thus is born commercial airport,
airplane government basically bankrolled
it as did as did a prize money for
accomplishing certain achievements like
lindbergh.
No one talks about the fact that there
was cash money available to him for
having done a flowing across the
atlantic solo first cash money.
No.
Yeah,
I did it for the money.
Yeah.
As most of them did fly the longest,
the highest,
the fastest.
Each of these had money associated with
it.
So this drove the marketplace.
It was not whether you could make a
product out of it initially because you
got to get over the early humps.
You got to get through to get to know
what it is that works and what doesn't.
So is there a plan with the space for so
like are they gonna make space weapons
and space ships.
There's a treaty in 19 sixties to which
we are signature.
Okay.
And I talk about intercessory to war.
It's again,
I hate.
I feel so bad doing this plugin.
No,
I feel so.
Let me hold it.
No.
Yeah,
you can.
You hold it?
Yeah.
I just feel.
But,
but it's,
it's the unspoken alliance between
astrophysics and the military.
You look beautiful with that.
Primarily because there is a bow and
arrow here being shot by sagittarius.
That became a weapon on a missile at a
10.
You're a bone arrow guy.
Oh yeah.
Last I checked.
Yeah.
You've got to fricking bone our in the
back room here.
Yes.
What are you afraid of?
Practice when the zombies come either
run out of bullets.
Tommy som.
I'm pulling that sorta check from
walking dead.
Oh,
excuse me.
The best weapon.
Everybody runs out of bullets.
Zombies are slow and her weapon is in
fact this.
Totally.
Yeah.
So what was I saying before I
interrupted myself,
a nurse who's who's paying attention out
there?
Weapon asteroids,
weaponizing space.
So there's the outer space treaty,
a treaty for the peaceful uses of outer
space and it was in 1967.
There's some modification since then,
but that's the basic one and we are
signature to it and so are the other
major countries of the world and we just
break out of the paris accord break out
of that god damn space pussy shit.
It's a beautiful document.
It tries to be very forward looking.
If there's an astronaut from another
country who is at risk,
then you will go to help them without
question.
It's very kumbaya.
Okay,
so one of my sort of.
Now that I'm old and tired and I just am
a realist,
it's why should we promise to not kill
each other in space when we are not
successful at doing that here on earth
and we don't even promise tonight.
I promise to do it here on her.
Yeah.
Who are we to say,
oh,
well we'll kill each other.
AnyBody in space,
we'll all hold hands,
but I don't have that much confidence in
human conduct.
I'm.
I become cynical over my years and I'm
angry.
Demonstrate to me that on earth you know
how to not kill one another,
then I'll believe your space treaty.
So what I'm saying here now,
given that there is a treaty that says
you can't put heavy weapons in space,
as I detail in one of the.
Oh by the way,
I have a coauthor on this.
I started doing this 12 years ago and it
was like,
I will never finish this for a thousand
years.
I brought in a coauthor office,
lang who is a longtime editor of my
essays that I've written for natural
history magazine.
Just give a shout out to my coauthor how
does that work?
So in this case,
sort of takes your stuff and stitches it
together.
In this particular case,
there are lots of ways we collaborated.
Um,
some of them I just dictated entire
chapters to her and but leaving out
certain details that would require a
nitty gritty of sort of research just to
get the right numbers in the right year
and the commander and the write this,
but I know broadly how it happened in
what sequence.
And so then she would take that and
shape that into a chapter.
Other places I would say,
you know,
this happened,
this happened and that happened.
She would say,
well that wouldn't fit the narrative as
it's coming together.
Let's drop the middle one and take the
other two.
And I say great.
So I'd write that up and she would
stitch it.
She would grafted is a better word into
the rest of what was going on.
So this is,
even though there are places here where
I speak in first person,
it's actually,
it's a co written project.
It's not ghost written,
it's not.
I'm just putting my name,
but somebody else wrote.
I mean,
I,
I write,
I know how to write.
So we're co authors on this,
but thanks for asking.
That was good.
Um,
so,
uh,
so here's a problem that we detail here.
People say I don't want weapons in
space.
Okay?
There's nothing more useless than a
space weapon relative to earth's
surface.
Okay?
If you're in space,
you're in orbit.
The think it through.
If I use your skull here,
that's okay.
Cool.
Okay.
If this is earth,
okay?
Everything more spherical here.
I guess not.
I'm using your skull.
So.
Okay.
Alright.
So this is earth.
Okay.
And I've got a satellite in orbit around
the earth and I say,
okay,
I'm going to weaponize the satellite,
put a bomb in it,
and I want to drop over some city.
Some,
some bad person wants to make that
decision.
Right?
Well what's the city when it.
Well,
it's up here somewhere.
So you to it halfway there.
So you gotta well no,
it's not just that these are not very
high above the planet and so you have to
like change the orbit to align it so
that it goes over your target
satellites.
Don't go over every spot on earth.
The only go over the orbit that had
print preset for it.
Okay,
we can already destroy a city with an
intercontinental ballistic missile and
we can aim that.
We can aim a miSsile to any place on
earth.
it'll get there in less than 45 minutes
and destroy the whole city with nuclear
weapons.
We can already do that.
There is no advantage to putting nixon
space if that's your objective.
Not only that supposedly is a rogue
satellite and it's messing with you.
It's beaming energy particles at you and
you want to take it out.
how are you going to take it out?
You're going to destroy it.
Oh,
now you break it into a million pieces,
a thousand pieces.
Now each piece is moving 18,000
miles an hour and put your own
satellites at risk.
That's the modern equivalent to in the
first world war when they said,
oh,
we have a good idea because we can't
shoot them in the,
in the trenches,
let's get them out.
So they have the mustard gas.
Oops,
the wind changed directions and all of a
sudden you become a victim of your own
weapon such as what happened in space.
If you go in and start exploding
satellites out of orbit.
So war in space is a differenT thing.
It's not what you think it would be.
What would they do?
So the outer peaceful use of outer space
treaty allows you to have defensive pr
things in space,
not offensive for defensive purposes.
It allows that.
So treaty aside though,
yeah,
what?
What could you do?
Could you.
I mean,
could you have a rogue state?
Could take out our gps satellites.
Okay,
but when render the military blind and
then you won't be able to pick up your
uber.
He won't have anyone to have sex with
tonight.
That's the range of stuff that gps
applies to.
Right?
And so it'll affect our economy,
it'll affect our security.
And then our navy can't talk to the air
force,
the air force can't talk to her and that
would Be bad.
Armies up wars are no longer fought just
by how many soldiers have you lined up
at the at the border.
It's what have you done strategically to
render your opponent a to just to render
it,
to weaken your opponent or render them
incapable of fighting you.
This is why the attacks on September
11th worked because we had a policy that
if someone wants to hijack a plane,
you follow their instructions.
You do not deny them their requests
because the assumption was that if you
deny the request,
they will start harming people and if
you follow the requests,
it will delay when they harm them.
If they harm them at all and maybe
everyone will end up Safe.
It was not in the game plan that they
would crash the plane on purpose.
Okay,
so September 12th,
you will never again be able to do that
to the american plane.
Forget the extra x rays that we're
doing.
A pilot will never relinquish the
cockpit ever again,
no matter who they're torturing in the
back of the back of the plane,
no matter what they're doing,
even if it's shooting people one by one
because the plane going down takes
everybody out.
So that was a pretty easy door to close
literally and figuratively,
but no one saw it coming.
You know what drives me crazy when they
put that drink cart [inaudible] the
hallway to protect the pilot when they
opened,
I asked him about that.
So it's just to delay you a fraction of
a second to give them a chance to go in
and lock the door.
Right.
It's,
it's,
you have to get through them and the
flight attendant,
that takes an extra second.
You can't just run in.
Plus they don't even allow you to stand
in the aisle while that's happening.
They'll tell you to sit down.
You sit down.
Correct.
Yeah.
So you have to get out of your thing,
charged the cart and get through the
cart and the flight attendant who will
be fighting for their life at this
point.
Okay.
And because the plane is everything,
right?
Yeah,
I've seen that opening.
No,
you can get through there.
Those ladies ain't gonna.
Stop man.
Nobody.
Who really is physically.
Joe rogan has already thought this
through.
Another thing that my mind does,
the point is you can,
I would never do it.
Of course you don't.
I,
I thought about that,
but I thought to myself the plane that
way because I was like,
I witnessed a September 11th for blocks,
six blocks away from a six walking
blocks for digital.
No,
because that was my view is blocked from
the south.
So,
but I have a camcorder,
footage of the explosion,
big explosion I've ever seen.
Um,
and by the way,
one thing I noticed is that there was no
shockwave.
I might've been the closest to
scientists to the event.
So I was,
all I could do was apply every bit of
physics that I know there was no
shockwave.
I said,
well,
how can we have an explosion in no
shockwave?
And I later learned if you had to kind
of make a deflagration wave,
if you atomize fuel and then you spark
it,
then the flame moves across the fuel.
It's not a,
it's not a shock wave,
it's just a deflagration wave and
therefore there's no shockwave and so
windows are not blown out a quarter mile
away as they were in Oklahoma city with
the giant bombed with him today to
timothy mcveigh.
A read.
Why am I bringing this up?
Um,
what was I talking about?
September 11th,
the plane.
Oh,
uh,
oh yeah.
So here's something I calculated.
I said if I was in a seven 67 and we're
about to crash into a building.
If I was in the last row of the plane,
how much time would elapse before the
front row crumbled
and it met me in the back row
given the speed of the plane going into
the building.
Five hundred miles an hour.
Well,
that's probably slower than that by
then.
I would say closer to 400.
I mean it's a known speed and I don't
know it,
but I don't think it was is because you
can't turn at that highest speed and it
had to like turn around and an ame,
I have to say it's about a second less
half a fraction of a second.
It's a fraction.
So the question is tiny,
how long does it take a plane to go its
own length when it's going at 400 miles
an hour.
That's the thing.
Second.
Yeah.
It's a fraction of that.
So it's like that's it.
You can't even process that.
So I figured the deaths were pretty
quick.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's basically instantaneous.
You are.
You are pulverized.
A pile of goo.
I think they're planning on making space
ships that can shoot down another space.
Ships.
So here.
So any space wars would not be war
between space and earth.
It would be between stuff in space that
that's all stuff in space,
space,
space to space.
Here's another question.
What are you gonna do with all that
stuff that's just floating around up
there?
The debris.
HoW about another task of a space for
it?
So why don't you clean up space for it
so that we can have tourism and not risk
our lives by a paint chip or going
18,000
or bolt or a nut moving at 18,000
miles an hour.
That'll put a hole straight through you.
Right?
So yeah,
I would like to see the portfolio of a
space force,
if there is a space for us,
broadened the scope of that to include
protecting us from asteroids and
figuring out a way to clean up the
debris of space.
Is there a concept in place?
No,
no,
no.
Boy,
when you look at that map,
and I know the map is not the scale,
but it shows you the known satellites in
space.
Oh,
well There it's to scale in the sense
that they're there.
There's that many,
many options.
Does this relative distance too,
but they have a lot.
You can see their orbital line so it
feels crowded,
but it's so crazy when you look at it,
it's just like,
like it's just littered and we're
continuing to launch new things up there
and I joke,
I say one of the reasons why we've never
been visited by aliens.
It's because they came to her.
What is all that junk?
What?
Oh crap.
We're not risking our love.
Let's go to another planet.
They didn't know the map of where
everything was and they had to calculate
their income.
Forget it.
They'll just take it off.
It's not worth it.
Yeah.
I mean,
when you're on your way in,
you have to think about it going around
and visiting another planet that had a
civilization and they left a lot of crap
in their atmosphere.
Well,
those,
that's not the debris.
That's.
Those are the satellites.
So,
uh,
if you thought that is debris.
No,
you got it.
So,
so the,
the air force tracks debris as does
nasa.
They both tracked debris and sometimes
launch windows of a spacecraft.
Pieces of shit that's floating around.
That's crazy.
You scrolling through all that fast as I
can.
That is so nuts were so crazy.
We've only been doing this for 60 years.
So you track it right?
What was the last first satellite for,
for shallow sputnik.
Excuse me?
What year was too far away from you slap
you?
Oh,
sorry.
Was it sputnik?
October fourth,
1957.
Fifty seven.
The first artificial.
Anything in orbit around the earth.
And on that day too,
it's still up there.
There was only one thing,
one thing only then only.
Wow.
From 57 to 2018.
So at 60 years.
Wow.
One thing that's crazy,
and now how many things?
Well,
there's getting the countless debris.
There's hundreds of active satellites.
There's thousands if you include the
dead ones and thousands of.
So we have no way to clean it up or
maybe some big vacuum one day,
I don't know.
But yeah,
space vacuum.
They'd have to be valuable.
You could probably sell space debrIs if
you brought it back to earth.
Yeah.
People are dumb.
They'd buy it.
wants the space to put your house on the
hill.
Yeah,
I won't put this over here.
Speaking of debris,
speaking of debris,
uh,
there was this asteroid that collided
with earth,
uh,
over a chai being in the soviet union in
Russia,
sorry,
just near the siberia.
In the ural mountains just on the coast
of siberia than the border of siberia.
That was visible to everybody in broad
daylight.
And you had to avert your eyes when it
happened and they felt a shock wave and
the shockwave broke windows and sent 600
people.
Nearly a thousand people to the
hospital.
What happened?
Well,
because they saw the light and they
came.
They got up from their table and went to
the window to see what had happened.
There's a time delay between the
shockwave and the light because light
travels fast and sound travels slow,
so we'll go to the windows in the shock
wave hits and it blasts broken glass
into their face,
so it's a big bandaid collision that we
had people all needed basically
bandaids.
Okay.
No one died,
but nearly a thousand people were
injured,
so at an auction,
but that actually exploded and pieces of
it were recovered at an auction.
I purchased a piece of that media.
Right,
but you're also purchased some of the
shards of glass that the shock wave had
broken.
What do you do with this shit?
I've got it.
It's just a habit.
I'm a.
I'm a part of.
It is a shot across our bow.
That's what that one died,
but it's a warning.
There's no better way to be warned then
to have a bandaid cover your injuries
that could have vaporized you or
rendered your species extinct.
What's crazy is the ones that don't even
make impact and still do devastating
damage.
Yes.
That didn't,
that one didn't touch earth.
Right,
right.
It incinerated 10,000
square kilometers of forest.
We'll get that honk.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
So February 15th,
2013.
And uh,
there was a haze over a half.
A ton of little rock was a thousand
pounds.
Oh yeah.
That's just a piece that made it
through.
Is it iron or the actual piece would
have been a about the size of this room.
So a small home.
wow.
So,
but yeah,
that's amazing that,
that small rug.
Go back up to that again.
Please look at the size of that.
That's not that.
No,
no.
That's what's left over.
Most of it is a vaporized on that,
on the explosion as it came through the
atmosphere.
Right.
But they're saying that that piece of it
weighs a thousand pounds a.
Do they give it the weight of it over a
half ton?
Yeah.
Oh,
we have to.
Yeah.
Thousand pounds.
That's crazy that,
that rock is that fucking have.
Yes.
So,
so yes.
Well I have to read that to know for
sure,
but I think it was an iron meteorite.
I'll tell you something.
I have a knife that was made out of a
piece of media or as do I though the
beautiful.
Oh yeah,
that's a kitchen knife that I use.
Oh,
see how mine is like a.
It's like a crocodile dundee knife.
That's not a knife.
That's a knife,
but it's waiting.
I want to make a or get someone to make
a handle for it.
It's just the.
It's just a metal that would be within
kitchens for.
It's a forged metal with the blade,
but then you get a pearl handle attached
to the base of.
Oh yeah.
So it's going to handle this an it's an
unadorned piece of metal that would
become a know the knife sharpening.
oh yeah.
Where's the fucking handle?
there is a metal hand.
Have you ever seen a kitchen?
Knives?
The metal goes all the way down in down
the center of the handle and you'll
screw wooden handles on the side.
So you just need the.
And I just need the wood or the or the
patent.
It would be pearl,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
I got handed revolver,
pearl,
pistol,
you know,
so.
So yeah,
it's a part of history and it's a
reminder that if you want to think about
the future of civilization,
you have to include a defense plan
against asteroids,
the dinosaurs,
dinosaurs.
I bet if they could,
they would have had a space program to
not go extinct.
No shit.
Thinking now,
is there anything that we're doing now
other than occasionally looking up?
Yeah.
We're looking with monitoring and
cataloging them.
Yeah,
but we don't really know what to do.
if it happened,
the day would come,
well,
we know what to do.
There's nothing funded.
We have their engineering conferences.
How would you deflect an asteroid?
How would you destroy us to see one in a
one way and commit 100 percent?
Just kiss your ass goodbye.
that's it.
We would.
We would have the power to tell you when
you would die and what part of earthy
would hit.
So there's people that have very
delusional ideas about what we can and
can't do with asteroids and that drives
me crazy.
No,
it's not that we know how to defeat the
scene.
The engineering plans,
they look very good,
but there's nothing in place,
right?
Because there's project sentinel you can
look it up,
that is,
has tasked themselves with organizing
world governments to protect earth from
species killing asteroids and you need
the world because you don't know in
advance until it's discovered what part
of earth it's going to hit and if it's
going to hit in the indian ocean and if
indian,
if,
um,
the surrounding regions don't have a
space program or are there countries
that do have a space program going to
sit idle?
Know what you want to do iS you want to
have a fund and every country pipes in a
little bit of their gdp and then or,
or whatever,
uh,
you know,
you measure it however you want.
Whatever you think is fair,
do it the way,
uh,
the way,
the un does it.
OkaY.
So there's attacks of the world relative
to your wealth.
And then that money pays to save the
world when we find such an asteroid that
that's how you at the sentinel project
sentinel is,
is,
uh,
has thought this through.
So if they're engineers and scientist,
ample time,
there's possibility,
there's a possibility that they could
actually implement some of these plans.
it's all about how much time you have,
because what you want to do is go out
and nudge it a little bit,
a little bit.
you just have to give it a sideways
velocity relative to its path towards
earth.
If you do that early enough,
the sideways velocity sort of
accumulates like a ship turning slightly
over the ocean of the course of time.
It'll deviate quite a bit.
Correct.
So that angle grows.
It's the same angle,
but it spreads out.
And if the ocean example is perfect,
there's a perfect analogy.
So if you do that early enough,
you do it enough so that it misses earth
and it's still out there to harm you in
another day,
but it won't render you extinct on that
passage.
How much time do we need today?
Uh,
if I would say we could probably get
something built in 10 years.
Oh geez.
What I'm looking for a month.
And that's.
Oh no.
Oh my gosh.
So a year.
If we have a year,
the good thing about species killing
asteroids is that they're large and
visible.
WhAt about city killing?
Ones them slip through.
They'll slip through,
but most of earth's surfaces,
not city,
so it'll probably hit the ocean or land,
but yeah,
If it does,
it would take out a city.
The whole city gone.
Yeah.
There's a branch of government part of,
I don't know if it survived the trump
changeover,
but it's a,
it's part of a homeland security were
worries about devastation to a region
where the grid is taken out as well.
So you can't bring emergency services
that bring either food,
water,
medicines,
uh,
any other form of transportation or
communication.
How much thought is there to putting in
a more robust grid?
Uh,
I,
yeah,
what you would need is,
that's a good point.
So you need a grid that can sort of,
a rewire itself rapidly to then bring
power to a region that's what you would
need.
And it would ditch sorta doing that now
making a grid,
sort of a lightening proof,
you know,
a power surge proof.
I grew up in New York city where there
were a couple of very famous blackouts
when in 1966 and other in.
When was it?
Nineteen 78 I think.
And uh,
it was like,
whoa,
how should this,
how is this even allowed?
You don't have a backup plan.
Yeah.
You have a way to rewire this to
redirect the electricity.
So yeah,
you'd need that and you'd want that.
And I thought the new grid is supposed
to have those kinds of protections built
into it,
but I don't know enough about it to
comment.
It is one,
one impact.
Oh yeah.
One big one takes out the grid.
It takes out the grid.
And then what do you have?
Solar power you place?
Uh,
we just put in solar panels.
Yeah.
You live in a place that's obviously we
have a place in the country escape to.
Yeah.
It's a good move to have that escape
spot.
Yeah.
You have a place in upstate New York on
long island?
Yeah.
I used to think of it as an escape
because we thought of getting after
September 11th.
Got it in.
Oh,
three.
two,
something like that,
but now it's just a good place for me to
refuel and through a lot of good writing
there and this sort of thing.
Look out for ticks and oh,
oh my god.
Long island's overwhelmed with lyme
disease.
They got a new tick apparently that
prevents you from eating meat,
vegetarians,
bread that think it's called the lone
star tick and it prevents you from
eating the meat of mammals.
Yes.
If it makes you allergic to alpha,
galactose,
is that what it is?
It's alpha gao.
Another great radio podcast.
Yeah,
I detail I think the vegans and
vegetarians,
I think.
Yeah,
I think they still eat fish.
Yeah.
Chicken eater mammal can't eat red meat.
It's something in red meat.
Yeah.
So that's one of the challenges,
right?
But damn ticks,
they are everywhere.
And we looked at it the other day.
There's,
because I have quite a few friends that
have lyme disease and it's something you
do keep for life.
And uh,
quite a few friends,
like seven or eight and I think at this
point that have devastating lyme disease
and it's all east coast people.
They were making love in the brush,
like what are they doing?
Walking around,
going for a hike.
You know,
I'm a city person,
so even though I moved to the country,
I go for a hike on my deck.
You don't go anywhere.
No,
no.
Sit back just a little on the deck.
Pay,
but you're out there in the gorgeous
country.
don't you want to go wander around a
little bit?
No,
it's honestly not a thought.
My wife was from Alaska has those
thoughts all the time,
but the power of ticks overwhelms her
power of curiosity.
Those are powerful people in Alaska.
That's a different type of their.
Their,
their,
their bread differently.
Oh,
they're strong.
Those people can survive and then they.
They have a sentence to say unity up
there.
It's really interesting that unity I
think comes from the fact that they're
all in the same risk factors together.
Yup.
And if,
if,
if you and I have the same things that
can kill us,
that makes us friends.
It's also they're overwhelmed by nature.
It's like they're overwhelmed by both
its beauty and just the sheer evidence
that you're insignificant.
I would say they're not overwhelmed.
They are wellmed,
but who's the right amount of wealth?
I have a buddy of mine who lived up
there.
A grizzly bear killed a moose in his
driveway who like what?
Right.
That's the kind of stuff in the
driveway.
They had to be careful like getting out
of the house because the bear had cashed
the moose when we first went up there.
My brother in law,
my wife's sister's husband kept a loaded
shotgun over their bed so that when the
door starts rattling in the middle of
the night,
the gun is in his arms reach and that
was good.
That was good.
Yeah.
Those fucking things.
You ever seen one in real life?
I mean,
zoo captive.
Not a real one.
Real one because there's a look.
They go,
no,
no.
we've visited denali park,
but I saw it's 500 yards away.
It's not any closer than that.
Denali park,
they're a little bit habitualized to.
Right.
No,
that was pretty wild.
Oh,
denali park it with jellystone park.
I'm thinking of something different.
Do you think in a jellystone park,
denali park is,
um,
where we're,
what is that near what part of Alaska is
that near?
It's got.
It's got mount mckinley,
denali,
the mountain in it.
So.
Oh,
so where is it?
It's uh,
I forgot,
uh,
geographically,
but that's not near the brooks range
right now.
I couldn't tell you.
I'm not,
I'm not a mountain range.
The sheer size of Alaska.
When you actually look at it over the
United States superimposed at you?
Oh yeah.
What,
what to know.
Another one with another one besides of
africa relative to the United States.
We've done that anytime.
So.
Excellent.
Everything fits in there.
Everything fits in.
He was like five.
United states can literally.
Everything fits in there.
It looks like most of the world that's
in there.
United states plus europe,
asia,
China,
China.
Yeah.
It's fucking crazy.
It's a giant place.
But what's really interesting about
Alaska is how few people there.
RighT?
You know,
I mean it's such a low density
population density,
so light,
but,
but anchorage is a really cool city.
Like if you go there,
you're like,
oh,
this is a cool ass town,
nice people.
But if you go there in the summer,
bring some things to cover your eyes.
Oh,
because when you go into bed at night,
you're going to bed during the day.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So,
so,
but my wife said in the winter when they
go to school and dark,
it's not nighttime,
it's dark.
They don't use night and day.
It's just dark and light.
Yeah.
Because it's the only light for a few
hours.
Yeah.
So that's light then it's dark.
She ever see that movie?
Um,
was it called 30 days of night?
Vampire movie about Alaska?
No.
Yeah,
the vampires came to.
It was actually pretty fun.
One vampire movie in my landlord,
vampire movies,
I have nothing against them.
They just don't let smart homes don't,
can't put that.
I don't see the romance of getting
bitten in the neck.
Well,
to stop romance.
It's scary actually.
I think the,
the,
the uh,
what's the other series?
Underworld.
The underworld series.
I've seen a few of those,
those like those,
those are fun.
Those are the dumbest ones.
The ones that the twilight fans make fun
of.
Oh no,
I just liked the fact that there's a
lead woman kicking ass.
Women.
Those guys.
Women who can go ahead do your show.
I love when you put on your little show.
We love when women are winning.
Yay.
Kick ass.
No,
it's just fun.
He must love alien.
The original alien.
Yeah.
That's good.
Talked about ripley from aliens weaver.
She's original female movie.
Bad ass.
Well,
no,
they go before her and I just reminded
myself of this.
Uh,
uh,
is it barbara rig barbarella?
No.
Barbara rig,
because her name,
she was the woman in the original
british series.
The avengers.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
But that was hokey,
like wait,
but she was wearing black leather and
new martial arts and kicked ass wasn't
believable but whatever was believable.
Like when she's shooting that thing,
like if you buy like,
look,
she's throwing gasoline on this.
This to me is like to you when you're
making fun of the mistakes that they
make in these movies about space.
This shit drives me crazy that people
just flip and peoples through the air
and then they fly off buildings.
Stop.
You're driving me fucking crazy.
Just like I have a tweet.
I'm thinking,
should I post it now?
Not too long.
I got to take one of those dangerous
guys.
It doesn't put a case on your phone.
You have the fucking gape in your back,
on your phone.
Your lock screen is the stonehenge of
manhattan.
Manhattan henge.
No case on your phone.
So you're a risk taker,
right?
No.
So you can think of it as risk taking or
when I got the phone,
because I admire how thin this is,
right?
I'd like technology serving me.
Okay.
So what I do when I got the phone,
I said,
let me do this with it.
Flip around.
Yes.
And I reminded myself,
why do,
uh,
in,
in the military cadets,
why do they twirl their gun of what
possible value is this in combat?
Why do they do these things with their
gun?
And then I realized you're not supposed
to drop your gun ever,
ever.
So if you twirl the gun and you don't
drop it,
it means stuff can happen to you in
combat and it is always attached to your
body.
So,
so when I got my phone I said,
let me just do this.
Okay,
If I pick up the phone and dropped it,
jesus christ.
So when you do that,
then you never drop your phone.
So it's not that I'm a risk taker is
that I've changed my risk to make it so
low that it essentially won't happen.
And you've got apple care to get apple
care.
I know you didn't know.
Of course I'll get applicants know
you're a risk taker first.
I fixed my own damn computer.
Second.
How are you going to fix your own damn
phone?
If the screen breaks,
you're going to get in there with a
screwdriver and pop that bitch out.
Put the new one,
the key word,
the key phrases there.
If the screen break going to drop it.
So that's correct.
I also carry relatively expensive
fountain pens.
What happens with that?
I never lose them.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
If you always lose your pens and meat,
you're not spending enough money,
right?
Like sunglasses.
Exactly the same pair of sunglasses.
NoW,
for a record number of times the medical
cost you $200 to get a fucking lose
them.
They're just my favorite ones for free.
Shout out the skeleton sunglasses.
Oh,
skeleton optics,
zeiss lenses,
zeiss.
Powerful fucking invented the
planetarium projector.
Did they realize they did make some bad
ass?
19,
23,
may 23.
But uh,
I'm at the same sunglasses now.
I think you're doing well here.
Six months.
He's fat.
Stupid fingers.
So once you,
once you get that,
then it doesn't drop.
So it's not that I'm a risk taker is
I've changed the risk.
So that is low enough so that it is on
par or on par with other risks that you
take routinely.
I smoke a lot of pot.
Dude,
this is going to drop.
I keep doing this.
Also the things,
if you pick up the phone with one hand
and it's upside down,
you hold it in places where the center
of gravity flips it,
but you also have some sort of a skin in
the back.
It's just,
it's just.
It's a sector of van gogh's.
Starry night.
Yeah,
but it's not.
There's no texture to this.
It's just a slippery.
It's slippery like,
oh,
it's a.
It's definitely more texture.
Feel that that's slicker.
It's complicated,
but it's not wise there,
but my point is that snow white and the
friction scientists,
you should recognize this friction is
good.
Yes.
I mean isn't that one of the things that
they decided to do to asteroids to
change their path,
spray some goo on them and it will
literally cause more friction in the air
and caused them to deviate slightly from
their path,
which over a long period of time.
I don't know where you just pull that
out of your ass.
Just that moment.
That moment.
No,
I've read that and maybe it was some
dummy who wrote it and either vacuum of
space.
There is no friction,
so some shit they could put on the wig
if it's traveling,
isn't there something they could put on
that would aerodynamically change its
path in the vacuum of space?
There is no aerodynamics.
Okay.
So it's moving by the time it hits her,
it's atmosphere.
It's too late.
So it ha.
So it's,
there was a coding that they were
planning on putting on some aspect of,
would it be the act of putting the
coating on it?
So what you would do is you may be
thinking of,
there's a coating you can put on an
asteroid that differently absorbs
sunlight relative to the other side.
Uh,
so it causes the spin that can,
that can create a net.
A vector of motion is spray.
Any asteroids can protect the earth from
space rock threat.
Okay,
so there you go.
That sounds like some click baity shit.
That's some click bait shit.
Okay.
Change the amount of sunlight reflected,
but you would,
you would not do that to the entire
rock.
you do it to a part of the rock
potentially nudging and away from earth.
And the accumulated push provided by
many thermo photons as they radiate from
the app.
Wow.
You asteroid surface.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
See,
I didn't think that through very well.
And somehow you added a key jelly to
this.
I'm trying to flip this phone still on
my friend andrew santinello.
He carries this pitch around case free
and I admire him.
He's braver man than I do.
I sent you a list of topics.
Did we hit all of them?
Yeah,
we hit all of them.
We didn't hit innovation in other
categories.
No.
Here's one.
Oh,
we never even got the cars.
Cars.
Why?
They'll never be flying cars.
Yeah,
man,
I.
Man,
I started with this please.
Okay.
Since we're two hours and 40 minutes in,
does that allowed?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah,
we're flying.
No,
but people don't have full three hours.
Do they?
Oh,
we do it all the time.
Really?
Are you Sure?
100 percent.
Yeah.
This is not you sure?
Average podcast right now.
Average.
Really?
Yeah.
Dude,
I'm honored to bleach your average.
The ones we've done.
We've all been like close to three
hours.
Okay.
Here you go,
here you go.
A ding.
Oh,
oh,
it's rude.
Okay,
so let me.
I flipped it.
I turned that goddamn switch on.
Okay,
so let's go back to flying cars.
Let's go back to why anyone would want a
flying car in the first place because
they're an asshole.
Okay?
Go here and stuck in traffic.
So here at edison,
everybody.
So let's watch.
Let's say there was only one road,
okay?
Okay.
There was the width of your car and
you're driving on this road and the cars
behind you.
The you could go
on that road is the speed of the slowest
car on the road,
right?
It makes sense.
Yes.
This is travel in one dimension.
That sucks.
What you really want is travel in two
dimensions.
So you take the road and why didn't it?
Let's make two lanes,
two lanes in one direction.
We can have two of the other way as
well.
This doesn't matter here you have two
lanes,
so now I can go around you your slow ass
car.
Okay?
But then that's fine.
This was a great improvement on one
dimensional travel.
Now it's two dimensions.
Okay.
I can shift left or right as well as
move forward or backwards to move and
the more lanes you have,
the more two dimensional that is.
Okay.
The four.
Oh,
five here in los angeles.
What is it?
Six lanes each is 12 fricken lanes.
Okay.
You are fully exploiting the two
dimensionality of travel,
but you still have so many cars that you
say to yourself,
I want to bypass this traffic.
If you went from one dimension to two
dimensions,
bypassing is just another lane,
but now all 12 lanes are plugged and you
want to bypass it.
So you're thinking I need to travel in
another dimension.
I want to travel in the third dimension.
If I do that,
I can bypass all these cars.
I want a flying car.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well the point is we already have flying
cars.
They called helicopters.
The helicopters originally invented for
that.
They called helicopters.
They're noisy.
They have to create a downward thrust of
air equal to its own weight.
If you're gonna have a flying car,
that's what it's going to have to do.
TheY're noisy.
They're.
They completely disrupt the terrain
wherever they fly.
So the issue is not that you want a
flying car,
you want to travel in that third
dimension,
[inaudible].
We already do that.
How do we do that?
Called tunnels.
They called bridges.
When you have a huge intersection,
you don't move people through one
another.
You build the,
you build one road over the other,
you build one road under the other,
you are exploiting three dimensions so
that traffic can go in perpendicular
directions simultaneously.
That's what the flying cars would have
given you.
But we do that at intersections because
it would be impossible to move 12 lanes
of traffic through an intersection that
crossed another freeway.
New york city has done this.
We do
the New York.
The you're in the streets,
there's too many cars you can't move.
Let's move in.
The third dimension,
let's build a subway.
This sounds like a guy who's trying to
sell me something,
telling you better than a flying car.
I'm just like,
listen man,
that flying cars bullshit.
You could buy a flying car.
The new.
I want you to appreciate moving in the
third dimension.
So New York city subway system moves a
billion people a year and they all go in
the third dimension beneath the ground
through tunnels,
tunnels that are layered on top of one
another.
Well,
the New York city subway system is
amazing.
How doubt about.
I couldn't move that many people.
It's great,
but it's not as good as a flying car.
It's not as cool as a flying car,
but it's as effective as a flying car.
The flying car,
personal flying car.
Just have to get in line.
You'd have to get on the subway.
You don't have to have a token,
you'd have to go through the turnstile.
You have to deal with some guy who's
ruBbing his body up against yours,
you know,
flying cars.
So you just fly around.
I'm just saying it's like a boat
tunnels,
but for the air and bridges are flying
cars.
Beautiful thing about a boat is you just
go wherever you want to go.
Now here's the thing,
it's kind of,
you don't have to call air traffic
control.
I was turning left.
I would take it to another dimension.
Not someone will have to know where the
hell you're flying.
Car is going just the same way.
Traffic rules that are in the street you
want,
there's not as it is with boats.
And you know,
what happens if a car failed?
False.
It's just on the ground.
At your stops flying.
Car fails.
You're dead,
right?
Okay.
So,
uh,
I want to add another dimension to this
conversation.
Oh,
are you ready?
On moscow's tunnels.
Okay.
Ready?
Exactly.
So watch,
here's a desk in front of me.
Okay?
Uh,
I,
it's a physical desk and I have a lot of
sheets of paper and,
and so I lay them side by side.
I tiled the desk with all my sheets of
paper.
Then there's no desk surface left.
I ran out of two dimensional space.
If I want to store more pages on my
desk,
what do I do?
I get one of those organizers.
I've just introduced a third dimension.
So now I could have pages in another
dimension sitting above the page that
was previously occupying another place
that I couldn't have put another sheet.
That's three dimensions?
Yes.
Okay.
If we were two dimensional people,
we would wonder what happened to that
sheet of paper because we have no access
to that third dimension.
It was just left our universe at this
point.
I'd be trying to back out of the
showroom and I'd say,
thank you,
but I'm going to go to the flying car
place so now watch,
but look at how much you've increased
your storage by introducing another
dimension.
Now imagine a fourth spacial dimension.
We don't have access to that,
but we're now filling all three
dimensions and afforded missional
creature will say,
well,
just put it up in this direction will be
the fourth dimension.
In that regard,
you can't imagine it because our brain
evolved in three dimensions.
We haven't.
We can describe it mathematically.
Maybe a wormhole in pasadena,
downtown la,
so our storage needs would be come.
You can open the door,
put it through this portal to the fourth
dimension and closed the door and look
on the other side of the door and
nothing would be there.
Yeah,
just the way on the surface of the desk.
If you live in the service desk,
so it opens a door,
they put the paper through the door,
close the door,
and you look around and say,
where did it go?
I have no idea because you can't even
see.
You can't even imagine that third
dimension.
We cannot imagine a fourth dimension,
but if the world one day gets so crowded
that even three dimensional space has
traffic,
access to a fourth dimension would
greatly help that.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Good luck with that.
Getting people to step through ice.
What is this jamie?
Some flying thing that just came out
last.
Oh,
look at this thing.
That cgi.
That part seemed cgi,
but it's actually flying over grass
that's moving and look at this thing.
What is it?
Solar powered.
I don't know.
Huh?
The trailer,
like showing it,
describing it,
but didn't have sound.
Does it make sound note?
It looks like it looks like a human
sized drone.
Yes,
that's exactly what it looks like.
Okay.
What about something like this?
What about something like this with
really powerful magnets all inside the
outer edge,
so it repels against other drones to an
a maglev flying car.
So if you get so close like,
oh,
I see it will be like a forcefield each
other.
Oh,
so it'd be like.
It'd be like a bumper cars.
Yes.
But with.
With cushions.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Some sort of electromagnetic force field
that everyone agrees that you don't have
the ones that are attracted to each
other but are opposed by the way you see
how big that human north human sized
drone it.
Have you ever heard how loud a drone?
it fucking loud.
You can't.
You can't even have a conversation.
Yeah.
I got an asshole in my neighborhood.
Flies on around you.
That's what shotguns are for you.
I wish I had never fired a gun in my
life.
The first time I've ever used one.
It's to shoot the drone that's going to
be looking through my window at my
apartment.
Oh yeah.
This is fucking asshole in my
neighborhood.
He flies all over people's yards,
but I can't uncork they already think
I'm crazy.
Still play.
And if I shoot it with a bow and arrow,
I'm not sure I'll hit it.
By the way,
did that video have a sound accompanying
with it?
Has some.
Some,
a little bit.
There's music and some description of
music,
but it's not the actual sound of those
propellers.
But they have on their webpage here that
it's quieter than a car on a freeway.
What is quieter than electric car?
Nor at 150 feet away.
Measured at a 150 feet.
That's incredible because it's about the
same as far as a car.
Well it says don't count.
So they're counting that as an electric
car though.
Oh,
they are?
Yeah.
Gasoline cars bottom.
But what is that about?
Cars today are not in top.
Wait,
just to be energy consumption.
I don't know if theY're using the same
icon to represent.
See,
they're using the same electric electric
car.
So it's the sound of an electric car.
No,
no.
There's no engine,
but no,
don't get deceived there because that's
energy consumption.
See,
energy consumption uses the same icon
for electric cars.
It does for gasoline car.
And then down.
No,
see it says noise.
It shows highway.
Just car.
It doesn't tell you what dba.
Yeah,
there's no way 76 dba sound because
electric cars far quieter than a regular
car.
The all you hear is the drone of the
tires.
So.
but what happens is above a certain
speed,
the,
the aerodynamic noise is greater than
the.
So it'll landing airplanes.
So here's,
here's what you do.
You live in la,
go to the in and out near lax,
which is right near a landing strip.
Okay?
Yeah.
And listen to the sound of the planes as
they come,
as they come in for a landing,
most of that sound is airfoil noise,
not engine noise.
A.
Yeah.
Which is why you can pretty much still
maintain a conversation.
You're old enough.
We remember a plane would fly overhead
in a city and you'd have to halt your
conversation until it finished.
Why?
What happened?
Engines got quieter and quieter,
which has enabled people to build real
estate closer and closer to airports and
not have not have a sound problem.
It's poor folks,
but they didn't happen overnight.
it was slow and steady.
No kidding.
Yeah.
I never.
I forgot her foil noise.
I forgot that you had to stop talking
when I remember it effect a shea stadium
in New York city near near laguardia
airport.
The announcers had to stop and he told
my plane,
flew over it.
They could.
That's when the mets won the world
series in 1969.
Mayor lindsay redirected the airport
traffic to not fly over the world series
games.
Why?
I thought that was a bad ass move of
him.
Of his mayor.
Lindsay.
Yeah.
I completely forgot how loud planes you
used to be.
correct.
And now they're.
Now they're,
it's a sound.
It's in the,
in the noise of the street.
You don't even stop and notice it.
You didn't even pay attention to all.
You barely hear.
You barely hear it.
And so next time you're at a runway when
it's landing,
it's much noisier.
Taking off because it's got a gain
altitude,
but coming down,
it's.
Most of that sound is glider noise.
And evidence of this is,
uh,
is,
the noise of air going over the air foil
of the fuselage.
If you do,
you know the moment they deploy the
landing gear,
next time you're in an airplane,
when they say we are clear for landing,
just listen,
listen to the ambient sound of the
plane.
Then listen to the sound after they
deploy the landing gear for three times
as loud,
it ramps up hard part because of the
sound of the air going around something
is not aerodynamic.
A fricken wheels.
Oh yes.
Yeah.
I just never.
For whatever reason,
I never remembered that.
Airplanes used to be louder.
I think about all the time.
So why can't I have a flying car?
You want the drone flying car?
Yeah.
So you need.
You wouldn't want it.
That would look ugly if two of those
collide and in the sky.
But what about my magnet theory?
Now?
Now it's got to have more power to lift
the weight of the magnet solar pro.
Plus he gets some testosterone infused
guy who doesn't want to let you ahead of
them to bump you.
That kind of break the propeller and
then you both fall out of the skus.
Sky rage,
sky rage.
There's a lot of dirage we know it'll
do.
It'll cull the herd of testosterone
driven men.
Okay.
But what if they do it,
but the only way they work is through
like the same sort of tesla system that
allows them to have automated cars.
Auto.
Yeah.
Know if you have automated cars,
you don't need flying cars because first
of be too many of them.
There'll be fewer cars on the road.
How do you figure that?
Oh my gosh.
Automated cars.
Fewer cars in the us.
How so?
Because,
because what your second greatest asset
your car.
Most people,
second greatest asset spends 90 percent
of his time doing nothing.
You drive to work and it's parked.
You come home and it's parked 90 percent
of his time doing nothing.
Okay.
I come to work 10 minutes after you a
half hour after you.
An hour after you.
I'm using your car.
You ain't using my card.
I'm telling you right now.
You're not using my car up.
No one's using the race car.
I forgot this is la.
Did you go to New York?
Happen for people where they steal your
car is a utility rather than a.
Something to try to get chicks with on
the street corner.
Oh,
stop.
He will try to get chicks in New York
too.
Don't do enough with the cars.
There's a lot of people that do.
Nobody has cars,
but if you do,
you're a baller.
You got one of them spots.
It cost you a thousand bucks a month,
baby.
I've seen some fancy cars and I've been
in New York system.
Fancy guns,
but that's not.
It's not.
It's not 100 percent.
Yeah,
but that's just that one stupid spot
where you still own the car,
but you'll be delegate relegated to a
lane where you won't be able to drive as
fast as the automatic or consider that.
If you're in a self driving car and it
wants to change lanes,
it communicates that to other self
driving cars near it and have self
driving cars tell you to fuck off.
You have a program like that.
Joe rogan upload rude russian bot call.
It's not letting anybody in the joe
rogan upload.
I feel like it wouldn't change anything
if there's automated cars and los
angeles.
I really do.
I don't think.
I don't think there'd be any less
traffic.
They're going to make a lane that'll
take automated cars and it will go 120
miles an hour and watching everybody
with their wasted horsepower in their.
In their inactive trapped,
stuck in traffic.
I was tweeting,
I was in la and I was in like a prius
and we passed a lamborghini doing 40
miles an hour and that was just seemed
so embarrassing to the lamborghini.
Doing 30 miles.
How are we doing?
Forty miles an hour.
We pass the lambert.
No,
it was like,
why do you have a lamborghini?
Because there's sometimes when there's
no one on the road,
not from what I've never seen.
Just kind of got a lamborghini drive
late at night and the lamborghini is the
peacock feathers as best as I can.
Judge.
You ever driven one?
No.
Two wonderful marvel of engineering and
science and she'd appreciate it.
A good thing goes zero to 62 and a half
seconds.
You're still burning gas.
oh,
you don't like gas?
Not if I don't have to.
You prefer electric.
Like if you had a car,
if you lived in it for whatever reason,
the planetarium decided,
look neil,
you're the best ever.
And we opened up the most amazing spot
ever.
it's in los angeles,
California.
We'd love you to relocate and start,
have a car.
I,
if I was forced to relocate and I had
only one car,
I'd get an electric car will probably
attempt to get a prius or a tesla.
Would you go?
Definitely tests.
Uh,
yeah.
You wouldn't want like their
performance.
Slice of cheese.
what is the biggest prius?
I'm just saying.
I know it's an important Car that set a
lot of other manufacturers into motion
to,
you know,
there's a dynamic to shitbox.
It is a dynamic.
That's one thing happens and the drive
something else that makes that happen.
But when you plug your car into the
wall,
you're not asking yourself,
I wonder where this power comes from.
It could come from any one of a dozen
sources like hydro.
It could be a pet solar panels or tidal
energy.
It could come from nukes,
it could come from oil or coal,
come from any of them.
what about clean coal?
Have you heard about this?
Clean coal.
The president's been tweeting about it,
clean coal,
all capital letters.
I'm like,
whoa,
I didn't know about that.
I thought it was just fucking cold.
Cold feet tweet is so here's my point,
if you can.
If you can power things with the choice
of a dozen sources of energy,
then those sources of energy compete
with one another for your business.
As the price of oil goes up,
he say,
I'm not going to generate power with
oil,
going to use the and I have a wind farm
and I come online.
I want to sell you my wind energy and I
and you're the power company.
You buy my wind energy.
You send that power to the wall outlet
and you charging your car.
Don't know and don't care where that
energy came from.
Whoa.
There's a book called turning oil into
salt.
Look it up so we caN mention turning oil
into salt.
Correct.
Why would you want to do that?
There was a day when salt was a
strategic commodity.
There was no other known
way to preserve food from the autumn
harvest to the spring set of crops.
So food got salted.
Okay.
Yeah.
uh,
that's the,
there's the book.
What's the woman's name?
A gal left and,
and koren.
Okay.
So I'm now describing the thesis of that
book.
Okay.
Turning oil into salt.
So here's what you do.
So we have soft.
If I took away your assault reserves,
you would starve over the winter.
So everybody knew where their salt came
from.
Everybody knew how much their salt cost.
Do you know,
do you realize that grant general grant
destroy the salt reserves or the
southern confederacy knowing that that
would force them faster to surrender
because they wouldn't have food reserves
to last through the winter.
I,
growing up net did not understand the
phrase,
you are the salt of the earth,
so it gives you high blood pressure.
What do you,
what do you mean?
The salt to their stop saying that.
That's not true.
Sodium does.
No.
Yeah,
it doesn't really have too much right
now.
Yeah.
Nope.
But let's get that in a minute.
Let me finish the thing.
So they give them something wrong with
you for that to happen.
Um,
so there's,
whether it's chronic or not that I agree
with you there.
If you're chronic high blood pressure,
it's not just this right?
But I can increase my blood pressure now
by not peeing and taking and ingesting
salt by not paying.
Why would you not pay?
Well,
because you retain the water and it gets
pumped through.
This is what the salt as you retain the
limit.
And it let me get back to the soccer
talking about.
Okay.
So,
so I said,
salt of the earth.
Why is that a Compliment?
I remember thinking to myself,
but there was a day when salt really
mattered.
Okay.
All right.
So,
um,
so what happens?
the 19th century,
we figured out how to can foods.
Ooh,
you can have berries and put them.
We Can.
Then we seal.
You can make preserves the name of the
food is what it is.
It's preserved.
Okay.
So now we this another way to protect
yoUr food,
to have it last through times when you
don't have crops.
Wait a minute.
Refrigeration,
get we have electricity.
You can refrigerate.
Wait a minute,
I can now fleece food.
I got a half dozen ways I can eat over
the winter and only one of them is salt.
So now salt has lost its strategic
value.
Lost his mojo,
lost his mojo.
It's still there.
We still eat salted foods as well as you
know,
over for flavor.
But it's a different thing.
Culture,
it's a different thing now.
It's a matter of choice,
not a matter of necessity.
A lot of great foods came out of that.
You know,
the salted pork and the bacon and the
very tasty foods came out of that
movement.
Okay.
So right now when you buy salt,
do you know where it came from?
No,
unless you get hawaiian salt,
that should get gourmet salt from foods.
You just buying morton salt.
Do you know where it came from?
No.
Do you remember how much it costs?
It's too cheap for eve viewed even.
Remember that?
Okay.
If you're going to turn oil into salt,
what you're doing is you're turning
energy into salt.
That's the value of a plug in the wall.
Design a car that can run on five
different kinds of energy than oil has
to compete with the other kinds of
energy.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
So have an engine that's a works on
hydrogen,
correct?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Hydrogen fuel cells.
Uh,
batteries.
So they have hybrids now that work on
two different things.
It's a start,
but my point is if you do that,
then we no longer fight wars for oil.
Oh,
what do we fight for now?
Maybe you don't fight for freedom.
How about freedom,
bro?
Freedom isn't free.
We just did three hours.
Three hours.
Holy
crazy.
How time flies by astrophysics for
people in a hurry.
That's.
This is old and it's all one on the New
York times bestseller list.
Crazy fact.
Seven 67 weeks.
Six to seven weeks.
The unspoken alliance between
astrophysics in the military.
It's not even to walk.
And of course you can preorder it,
but it's not out yet.
They'd like it if you pre order so they
know how to print in the thing.
I got it.
I got greasy hands.
If you're not in a hurry,
I'm learning some things that you're not
looking.
I'm reading.
Don't buy this book if you're not in a
hurry.
Yeah,
this is a.
This is a long form book.
Yes.
Gentlemen,
you got to do some thinking.
There's no pictures I just checked.
That's why you never know neil degrasse
tyson.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Oh,
startalk radio.
It's on podcast.
It's also nat geo.
It's on sirius xm channel 1:21.
The inside channel.
I might have a and cosmos.
Look for cosmos in the spring.
Beautiful date isn't announced yet.
Thank you,
sir.
Pleasure.
Always love you,
man.
Love you too.
Alright,
bye everybody.